Ties, ich versuche aus Null die Anwendung IMO Resolutions zu starten. Steht kein Zugriff auf Server-GLHV3. Bitte korrigieren Sie das ganz schnell. Ich sage es nochmal ganz schnell. Ich muss hier arbeiten. Ich kann es mir nicht leisten, ständig auf irgendeinen Scheiß zu warten, den die Idee nicht auf die Reihe kriegt.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 128, so eine Art Jubiläums-Sendung für die Freunde der Zweierpotenzen. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ja, ich begrüße euch zu einem neuen Thema mit brennender Aktualität, denn wir schreiben ja das Jahr 2009 und wie ihr alle wisst, fahren wir mit großer Geschwindigkeit gerade auf die nächsten Bundestagswahlen in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland zu. Nicht der einzige Grund, aber auf jeden Fall einer von vielen, hier mal das Thema Wahlrecht und Wahlsysteme aufzugreifen. Darum soll es heute gehen und ja, dazu begrüße ich Martin, Martin Fehndrich. Hallo. Ja Martin, du bist ja auch einer Internetgemeinde schon etwas näher bekannt, denn du betreibst eine Webseite, die einfach schlicht wahlrecht.de heißt. Was kann man da so drauf finden?
Ja, da kann man alles Mögliche drauf finden, was wir so in den letzten zehn Jahren zu Wahlrecht-Wahlsystemen zusammengetragen haben. Aktuelle Sachen, die verschiedenen Wahlsysteme der Bundesländer, Bundestags-Europawahlen, Kommunalwahlen, Wahlergebnisse. Die aktuellsten Umfragen findet man da immer. Ja, und eine Dokumentation von verschiedenen Wahlprüfungsverfahren, nicht zuletzt die, die wir selber durchgestritten haben.
Das heißt, also wir ist, wer?
Wir, das bin ich, Matthias Kanto und Wilko Zicht. Wir machen das also zu dritt, teilen uns das, beziehungsweise haben am Anfang dann verschiedene Themensachen zusammengeworfen und dann auf wahlrecht.de zusammengefasst.
Das heißt, ihr begleitet im Prinzip schon die Wahlen auch sehr umfangreich, aber ihr habt natürlich einen Fokus, wie dein Name ja auch schon sagt, wahlrecht.de. Es geht schon vor allem auch um die Rechtslogik hinter dem Wahl. Was ist denn so dein persönlicher Hintergrund, dass du dich mit solchen Sachen beschäftigst? War das irgendwann in den Internet-Topf gefallen oder...
Ja, ja gut, so ganz am Anfang war das mit dem Internet noch nicht so sehr. 1994, nach der Bundestagswahl, da hatte ich also mal versucht, das Bundestagswahl-Ergebnis nachzurechnen, weil da irgendwie so Überhangmandate aufgetreten sind. So ganz hatte ich das da noch nicht verstanden. Ja gut, und dann habe ich ein bisschen gerechnet bzw. erst mal versucht, rauszukriegen, wie das überhaupt funktioniert mit dem Wahlsystem.
Hast du einen mathematischen Hintergrund, eigentlich?
Ich habe Physik studiert und kurz für mein Diplom, da hat man natürlich alles andere zu tun, außer zu lernen. Und dann habe ich mir gedacht, rechtes Mal, Bundestagswahl-Ergebnis nach, sucht ihr mal irgendwie das Gesetz raus, versucht das zu verstehen und sucht ihr die genauen Zahlen raus. Ja, und als ich dann versucht habe, das eben nachzuverziehen, dann dachte ich mir, sehr irgendwie merkwürdig, wenn die Leute, die da in Bremen jetzt SPD gewählt haben, wenn sie das jetzt mal nicht gemacht hätten, dann hätte die SPD doch noch einen Sitz mehr bekommen. Oder halt umgekehrt. Also irgendwie funktioniert der Mechanismus nicht so richtig, wie man sich das bei der Wahl vorstellt.
Und was muss man denn überhaupt jetzt alles heranziehen? Du warst ja mit dem Thema zu dem Zeitpunkt noch komplett unvertraut.
Das war jetzt noch gar nichts. Also ich habe, glaube ich, zuerst das Wahlergebnis so gehabt, dass ich die einzelnen Zahlen von den einzelnen Ländern hatte, was die Parteien da bekommen hatten. Und damit habe ich dann das Wahlergebnis eben nachgerechnet.
Und kriegt man die hier? Die kriegt man vom Bundesamt für Statistik? Oder gibt es die überhaupt so in digitaler Form? Oder muss man die sich abschreiben?
Ich glaube, die standen in der FAZ drin, dass ich die da abgeschrieben hatte.
Also hast du dich echt mit so einer Doppelseite dahingesetzt und die einfach abgetippt?
Ja genau, dann habe ich die abgetippt, in den Excel-Sheet reingehauen und das dann auf der Ebene dann halt nachgerechnet mit der Verteilung, Ober- und Unterverteilung. Und ja gut, danach hatte ich dann ungefähr den Eindruck, wie das mit dem Wahlsystem laufen muss.
Was heißt das Ober-
und Unterverteilung? Bei der Bundestagswahl verteilt man die Sitze proportional in zwei Schritten. In dem ersten Schritt bekommen die Parteien ihre Sitze. Also die CDU hat so und so viele Stimmen, kriegt dann so und so viele Sitze. Die SPD hat so und so viele Stimmen, kriegt so und so viele Sitze. Die CSU extra kriegt so und so viele Stimmen, so und so viele Sitze. Bei den anderen auch, also die, die über 5 Prozent sind. Und danach guckt man sich an, aha, die CDU kriegt jetzt irgendwie 200 Sitze. Und zwar hat sie in Baden-Württemberg so und so viele Stimmen bekommen. Das sind dann so und so viele Sitze. Und in Nordrhein-Westfalen und Bremen und Berlin und entsprechend weiter werden diese Sitze dann unterverteilt. Das sind also die zwei Schritte der Sitzverteilung.
Also unterverteilt sozusagen an die Landeslisten.
Genau, das ist dann die Unterverteilung an die Landesliste. Also ein zweistufiges Verfahren an der Stelle. So, und dann läuft eben parallel das noch mit den Direktmandaten, die dann irgendwie angerechnet werden. Das heißt also für jedes Direktmandat, was man gewonnen hat, muss man halt wieder ein Listenmandat wegnehmen. Und wenn man zu wenige Listenmandate hat zum Wegnehmen, dann darf man die Direktmandate dann trotzdem alle behalten. Das, was dann als Differenz entsteht, das sind die Überhangmandate.
Da werden wir auf jeden Fall noch ausführlich zu kommen, ja.
Genau. Und das ist dann die Sitzverteilung, die sich dazu...
Okay, das heißt, du hast jetzt im Prinzip die ganzen Ergebnisse, also die ganzen Ergebnisse im Sinne von die tatsächlichen einzelnen Ergebnisse jedes einzelnen Wahlkreises genommen oder mehr schon so die Gesamtgeschichte von den Ländern?
Die Gesamtgeschichte von den Ländern.
Daraus kann man schon einiges ableiten.
Genau, also man braucht die Ergebnisse in den Ländern, wie viele Stimmen hat eine Partei im Bundesland X bekommen und eben wie viele Wahlkreise hat sie in dem Bundesland X bekommen. So und mit der Information kann man dann die Sitzverteilung nachrechnen.
Und was hast du dann festgestellt?
Ja, da habe ich dann festgestellt, dass in Bremen die SPD, wenn sie mehr Stimmen bekommen hätte, eine Überhangmandat verloren hätte. Wenn jetzt also in 2000 Stimmen oder so war, glaube ich, ein Beispiel, wenn jetzt also in Bremen 2000 Stimmen mehr bekommen hätten bei dieser Bundestagswahl, dann wären von diesen vielen Überhangmandaten schon mal eins weggefallen. Das heißt, die SPD hätte insgesamt einen Sitz weniger bekommen, wenn sie jetzt in Bremen 2000 Stimmen mehr bekommen hätte. So, danach habe ich dann noch irgendwie noch weitere Beispiele rausgekriegt, aber das war jetzt sozusagen die Initialzündung, wo ich gesagt habe, das kann eigentlich gar nicht sein. Eine Wahl heißt, wenn man viele Stimmen bekommt, dann kriegt man auch viele Sitze und für zusätzliche Stimmen, da kann man eigentlich nur mehr Sitze bekommen. Oder von mir aus genauso viel, weil das jetzt nicht reicht, aber nicht weniger. Weniger geht einfach nicht.
Diese Diskrepanz mit Überhangmandaten ist ja im Prinzip eine direkte Folge davon, dass wir ja nicht eine Stimme haben, sondern zwei Stimmen haben, kann man das so sagen, dass dieses Zwei-Stimmen-System schon schuldig ist?
Nicht direkt. Wenn man jetzt annimmt, man hätte nur eine Stimme, dann kann das genauso passieren. Du kannst aber mit zwei Stimmen darauf reagieren. Du kannst natürlich jetzt sagen, okay, ich gebe jetzt meine Erststimme der Partei, weil das ist immer gut. Und mit der Zweitstimme, die kriegt die Partei jetzt, aber nicht, weil das kann ihr ja schaden.
Okay, gut, also hat nicht zwingend was damit zu tun. Aber bleiben wir vielleicht nochmal kurz bei deinem Nachrichten, bevor wir jetzt hier voll in die Wahlgeschichte einsteigen. Also du hast das nachgerechnet und hast dir gedacht, okay, da stimmt doch was nicht. Das ist doch irgendwie braun. Kann es sein, dass eine Partei weniger bekommt, wenn sie mehr gewählt werden würde? In dem Fall ist das ja nicht tatsächlich passiert, sondern es hätte nur sein können.
Jaja, das ist ja immer so.
Oder hast du auch Sachen gefunden, wo es tatsächlich so war, dass da mehr Stimmen auf einmal auffliefen und dadurch...
Gut, du bist auf einer Seite von dem Sprung, ist man ja immer. Aber da man nur ein Wahlergebnis hat, ist man eben auch nur auf einer Seite. Die Geschichte, wo es dann wirklich gesprungen ist, war dann sozusagen die Nachwahl in Dresden, wo man wirklich zweigerechnete Ergebnisse nebeneinander legen kann. Aber das jetzt ein bisschen später. Ja gut.
Vielleicht ist es noch mal so zu deinem persönlichen Engagement. Also du bist dann sozusagen an dem Thema aber auch drangeblieben.
Ja klar, da bin ich drangeblieben und dann habe ich mir gedacht, ja gut, da gibt es jetzt irgendwie so eine Beschwerde wegen den Überhangmandaten. Und hier das Land Niedersachsen, das hat er auch geklagt. Und da gab es dann auch irgendwann das Verfassungsgerichtsurteil. Das war dann 1997, wo die gesagt haben, ach, das mit den Überhangmandaten ist nicht so schlimm. Also mit einer 4 zu 4 Entscheidung, also so eine klare Entscheidung, war das nicht. Das war dann sozusagen diese unklare Entscheidung, die sich jetzt dann noch durch die Jahre zog, weil dann nicht so ganz klar gesagt wurde, also Überhangmandate sind verfassungsgemäß oder auch nicht, wurde da also eben nicht so klar entschieden. Aber dieser Punkt mit dem negativ wirkenden Stimmen, die wurde da eben noch nicht angesprochen. Beziehungsweise, das hatte ich dann später rausgekriegt, wie ich das Urteil gesehen hatte, das wurde wohl im Verfahren angesprochen, aber hat da keine Rolle gespielt. Wenigstens habe ich mir dann gedacht, ja gut, wenn ihr das jetzt übersehen habt, schreibt doch mal einfach die Politiker von den Parteien an und erklärt das und wenn die sich das dann durchlesen, dann wird da vielleicht einer was machen. Das ist so die naive Herangehensweise, wie man das vielleicht als ersten Schritt versucht. Gut, also so viel Sinnvolles ist dabei nicht rausgekommen. Allerdings, einen Brief, den hatte ich...
Also du hast das dann aber auch versucht.
Ich habe das versucht, ja. Ich habe die alle angeschrieben oder auch, was die in der Debatte zum Wahlrecht danach mal gesagt haben, dass ich geschrieben habe, das was ihr da erzählt habt, das stimmt doch nicht so ganz. Und den Brief, den ich dann an Frau Süßmuth, der...
Rita Süßmuth, damit wahrscheinlich noch Bundestagspräsidentin.
Genau, als Bundestagspräsidentin geschrieben habe, der ist dann halt sozusagen als Petition bearbeitet worden. Und das wurde dann halt erst mal direkt weitergereicht an den Bundeswahlleiter. Da hat die irgendwie immer so einen komischen Brief geschrieben, rechnen sie halt mal nach. Dann kam auch zurück, jo, das stimmt, kann passieren, aber ist doch alles nicht so schlimm. Und Überhangmandate, die sind auch nicht so schlimm. Ein Fehler, oder was heißt ein Fehler, was ich an der Stelle gelernt hatte, war, ich hatte in dem Brief geschrieben, das hat doch mit der Gleichheit der Wahl auch alles nichts zu tun. Und dann kriegt man dann auch ungefähr zehn Seiten, nicht ganz zehn Seiten, aber fast von irgendwelchen Entscheidungen, von irgendwelchen Verfassungsgerichten, wo dann drinsteht, dass es mit der Gleichheit der Wahl alles ja doch nicht so wichtig ist und man das nicht so ernst nehmen muss. Ja, und da hatte ich mir dann gedacht, mit der Gleichheit der Wahl schreiben wir das nächste Mal nicht rein. Das ist nicht so wichtig. Gleichheit der Wahl stört mich nicht. Überhangmandate habe ich auch nichts gegen. Aber das hat ja was mit der Unmittelbarkeit der Wahl zu tun, weil wenn man eine Stimme abgibt, dann muss die eben für eine Partei wirken. Wenn die dagegen wirkt, dann geht das irgendwie nicht. Der nächste Punkt war die Freiheit der Wahl. Also wenn ich eine Partei wähle und will die damit unterstützen, aber die Partei wird dadurch bestraft, dann schränkt mich das ja irgendwo ein, dann mache ich das nicht. Und der dritte Punkt war, dass ich gesagt habe, ist das überhaupt wirklich eine Wahl, wenn man eine Stimme abgibt und dann kriegt die Partei, die man unterstützen will, weniger Stimmen, dann ist ja irgendwo irgendwie was Gegenteil.
Woraus leitest du diese Prinzipien jetzt ab? Aus dem Grundgesetz oder aus dem Wahlgesetz?
Das ist jetzt, sag ich mal, das, was man sich darunter vorstellt. Das ist ja nicht so genau geregelt.
Das ist ja ein eigener Interpretation. Das ist jetzt erst mal ein klar definierter Begriff.
Genau. Da kann man natürlich sagen, die Gleichheit wird natürlich dadurch verletzt. Aber da muss man ja nicht unbedingt das falsche Stichwort geben. Ja gut, und mit der Rangehensweise hatte ich dann auch bei der nächsten Bundestagswahl, also 1998, Anspruch eingelegt. Das läuft dann so, dass die erste Instanz ist der Bundestag selber, der gewählt worden ist.
Also nach der Wahl. Das kann man ja nur danach machen.
Man kann also nicht vor der Wahl, vor der Wahl kann man versuchen, irgendwelchen Leuten zu sagen, dass das mit dem Wahlgesetz nicht so richtig ist. Aber im Prinzip kann man gegen Fehler immer erst nach der Wahl angehen. So, dann hatte ich denen also einen Brief geschickt. Also an den Bundestag kann jeder Wahlberechtigte das machen. Und dann eben reinschreiben, wo die entsprechenden Überhangmandate aufgetreten sind, die nicht aufgetreten wären, wenn die Partei da mehr Stimmen bekommen hätte. Oder andersrum, wo die Partei Sitze nicht bekommen hat, weil sie da so ein tolles Ergebnis bekommen hat. Eine Liste von Beispielen und dann eben das mit der Unmittelbarkeit und Freiheit gesagt, dass das dagegen verstößt. Und dann nochmal betont, dass das mit der Gleichheit und mit diesem Überhangmandat an sich dann doch nicht so schlimm ist. Ja gut, und dann lässt der Bundestag das erst mal ein Jahr liegen, dass er sich dann an die ganzen Beschwerden traut. Das wird dann eben mehr oder weniger abgebügelt und gesagt, das ist nicht so schlimm. Und die nächste Stufe ist dann immer auch das Bundesverfassungsgericht, was in dem Fall dann allerdings auch abgebügelt wurde. Da gibt es also einen von diesen acht Richtern, der ist dann der Berichterstatter. Und der Berichterstatter schickt einem also so eine Art Bedenkenbrief. Er sagt, es gibt also Bedenken gegen die Erfolgsaussichten ihrer Wahlprüfungsbeschwerde, die dürfen sie jetzt auch zurückziehen. Und inhaltlich stand dann was, ja, sie bemängeln, dass das mit der Gleichheit der Wahl alles nicht so toll ist. Na gut, und an der Stelle merkt man dann, die haben sich das gar nicht angeguckt, die haben das nur irgendwo in eine Schublade einsortiert. Und ja gut, dann weiß man auch, warum es gescheitert ist. So, das war also nach der Bundestagswahl 1998. Also die Ablehnung kam dann, glaube ich, schon 2001 war das dann. Das zieht sich alles dann hin. Man muss ja auch dann noch die Unterschriften sammeln überhaupt, bis zum Verfassungsgericht gehen zu können. Da muss man also dann 100 Leute überzeugen, dass sie dann einmal unterschreiben dürfen. Den Zweifel überzeugen. Ja, und gut, das war es an der Stelle. Ja gut, und wie ich dann halt in dem Thema drin war, dann liest man sich eben auch ein und dann guckt man, was gibt es sonst noch bei Wahlrecht? Wie sieht das in den Ländern aus? Und dann habe ich eben versucht, das Ganze auf einer Internetseite zu dokumentieren.
Das heißt, danach hast du wahlrecht.de gestartet?
Genau, also die Domänen selber, die haben wir Anfang 1999 gehabt und auf der Seite zusammengefasst. Der Anlass war mehr oder weniger, dass ein Artikel bei Spektrum der Wissenschaft erschienen ist. Und da wollte ich da nicht irgendwie so eine Uni-Adresse hinterlegen, was sich dann auch relativ schnell als gute Idee herausgestellt hat, weil die Uni-Adresse danach irgendwie weg und anders war. Und so hatte ich dann halt eine eigene Seite, wo ich das dann alles dokumentiert hatte.
Das war aber jetzt nicht der letzte Einspruch, den du gemacht hast 1998?
Das war nicht der letzte, das war der erste Einspruch. Auch wenn er natürlich relativ erfolglos verlaufen ist, haben wir sogar einen kleinen Erfolg gehabt. Der eine kleine Erfolg war, dass wir vorgeschlagen hatten, dass man das Herr-Niemeyer-System wegen einiger Paradoxien vielleicht durch das Saint-Lague-System ersetzen soll. Was dann als Anregung aufgenommen wurde und wo gesagt wurde, jo, das soll die Bundesregierung mal alles prüfen. So und als der Einspruch an sich landet dann auch in der Bundestagsdrucksache, wo dann drin steht, was man bemängelt hat und warum man das bemängelt hat. Und in der Hinsicht ist es jetzt also auch dokumentiert, was bei dieser Bundestagswahl eben schiefgelaufen ist, beziehungsweise was an dem System kritisiert wurde.
Und jetzt ist das ja auch so, bei der nächsten Bundestagswahl wird anders ausgezählt werden.
Ja, nicht so richtig. Gut, das ist jetzt die längere Geschichte mit dem Urteil von letztem Jahr. Bei der nächsten Bundestagswahl wird das System Stronlogie eingesetzt, sozusagen der kleine Mini-Erfolg, der sich dann so über die Jahre irgendwann doch durchgesetzt hat. Allerdings wird noch einmal gewählt, dass Überhangmandate und vor allem negatives Stimmgewicht auftreten kann. Also die Wähler in einigen Bundesländern, von mir aus jetzt in Baden-Württemberg, die können sich also schon mal darauf einstellen, dass eine Stimme, die die CDU bekommt, ihr nicht unbedingt nützt.
Gut, dann würde ich sagen, müssen wir jetzt auch mal das noch mal von vorne aufrollen, damit man das irgendwie auch versteht. Also es soll gewählt werden. Wir haben ein Parlament, da sitzen dann irgendwie knapp 700 Leute und die sind natürlich vom Volk bestimmt. Jetzt muss irgendeiner Form von diesem Volk auch gewichtet werden, wer denn da nun rein soll. Jetzt wissen wir, alles wird über Parteien gebündelt. Es gibt aber auch direkt Kandidaten, die zwar im Sinne einer Partei sind, aber die, wenn sie gewählt werden, eben auch direkt im Bundestag landen. Alle anderen, die im Bundestag vertreten sind, die andere Hälfte ungefähr, die zieht quasi indirekt ein, weil sie auf einer Parteiliste steht. Und je nachdem, wie viele Stimmen diese Partei bekommen hat, wird dann eben von oben weg so viele Sitze, wie der Partei eben zugeschlagen werden, von dieser Liste reingenommen. Und dann wird das Ganze mit diesen direkt Kandidaten noch verrechnet. Jetzt mal so als grober Überblick. Aber fangen wir nochmal irgendwie an. Ich marschiere jetzt in die Wahlkabine, dann habe ich irgendwie so meinen Zettel und ich darf zwei Stimmen vergeben.
Genau.
Die Erststimme und die zwei Stimmen. Was bewirken diese Stimmen?
Genau, die Erststimme bewirkt im Wesentlichen, dass man einen Kandidaten im Wahlkreis, jede Partei, und von mir aus auch irgendwelche Leute, die nicht in der Partei sind, treten da an. Und wer von denen die meisten Stimmen bekommt, der ist also gewählt. Da gibt es dann eben 299 von, also 299 Wahlkreise haben wir jetzt. Ja, das war das mit den Direktkandidaten und der Erststimme.
Aber das heißt ja schon, dass an der Stelle quasi ein Mehrheitswahlrecht gilt.
An der Stelle gilt ein Mehrheitswahlrecht, was allerdings mit dem Verhältniswahl so verrechnet wird, dass von dem Mehrheitswahlrecht in der Regel nichts übrig bleibt.
Aha, also du meinst, es ist nicht so, dass wenn jetzt der eine 51 Prozent bekommt, der andere 49 oder die andere, dass dann diese 49 Prozent überhaupt keinen Einfluss haben?
Die Erststimmen haben dann keinen Einfluss. Da haben also nur die Stimmen, die der Erste dann brauchte, einen Einfluss. Allerdings auf die Verteilung zwischen den Parteien hat das erstmal grundsätzlich keinen Einfluss, weil von den Leuten, die dann über die Liste gewählt werden, wird dann immer einer weggestrichen, wenn von seiner Partei einer direkt reingekommen ist. Das heißt also, wenn ich jetzt einen Kandidaten meiner Partei jetzt über die Erststimme hier in den Bundestag reinwähle, dann heißt das nicht, dass die deswegen einen mehr haben, sondern die haben dafür einen anderen. Das heißt, der Kandidat X ist jetzt reingekommen, aber dafür kommt die Kandidatin Y nicht rein, die dann auf der Liste vielleicht den Sitz bekommen hätte. Oh, das ändert vielleicht auch gar nichts, weil der Kandidat auf der Liste, der da nicht reinkommt, ist der Kandidat X, der auch im Wahlkreis gewählt wurde. Das heißt also, das Ergebnis im Wahlkreis hat überhaupt keinen Einfluss.
Ja gut, aber es ist schon so, dass dann sozusagen diese nicht für den Gewinner gestimmten Erststimmen als solche nicht mehr in irgendein Algorithmus einfließen. Die sind weg.
Die sind weg.
Okay, gut. Jetzt die Zweitstimme.
Da steht dann ja auch immer auf dem Wahlzettel dabei, dass das die grundlegende Stimme ist für die Verteilung im Bundestag. Die Zweitstimme sagt also oder alle Zweitstimmen sagen, wie viele Sitze eine Partei insgesamt bekommt. Das heißt also, wir alle Sitze oder 598 Sitze, die werden anhand der Zweitstimme proportional an die Parteien verteilt. Das heißt proportional an die Parteien, die über der Sperrklausel sind. Also der 5-Prozent-Hürde oder der Grundmandatsklausel, wenn eine Partei weniger als 5 Prozent hat, aber mehr als drei oder mehr Direktmandate. Die Parteien, die gehen also in den Proporz. Die Stimmen werden also dann erstmal proportional an die Parteien verteilt. Und dann im zweiten Schritt, also die Unterverteilung, das hatten wir eben, an die einzelnen Landesverbände der Partei.
An dieser Stelle gilt auch die 5-Prozent-Hürde.
An der Stelle gilt...
Sie sieht ausschließlich auf die Zweitstimmen.
Die bezahlt sich ausschließlich auf die Zweitstimmen. Wenn jetzt eine Partei ein Direktmandat gewonnen hat, aber nicht 5 Prozent bekommen hat, dann darf sie dieses Direktmandat behalten. Das wird dann sozusagen auch aus dem Proporz rausgenommen. Wenn sie zwei gewonnen hat, darf sie die auch behalten. Das gab es ja auch bei der vorletzten Bundestagswahl 2002 mit den beiden PTS-Kandidatinnen, die in Berlin gewählt worden sind und die dann als Minigruppe im Bundestag saßen oder als fraktionslose Abgeordnete.
Ab drei können auch eine Fraktion bilden.
Ja, ne, ne, ne Fraktion. Da muss man glaube ich schon 5 Prozent sein. Von der Bundestagsdefinition her, was eine Fraktion ist. Ich frage mich jetzt nicht, was eine Gruppe ist, die da irgendwelche Sonderrechte hat. Das ist ein bisschen kleiner. Aber mit 3 gilt die Grundmandat-Klausel. Das heißt also, wenn eine Partei 3 Direktmandate gewinnt, dann gilt die 5-Prozent-Hürdel nicht.
Das heißt, dann zählt auch eine 2- oder 3-Prozent-Zahl. Und das wurde auch von der Liste reingeholt.
Genau. Das gab es also einmal 1994, wo die PDS keine 5 Prozent bekommen hat, sondern nur irgendwie 4. Aber da haben sie halt 3 Prozent.
So davon ausgehen, wenn 3 von unseren Kandidaten in bestimmten Wahlkreisen so wichtig sind, dass sie dort die Stärksten sind, dann hat die Partei auch überregional eine Bedeutung per Definition und dann gilt einfach die 5-Prozent-Hürde nicht mehr.
Das ist dann so die letzte Hürde für die CSU oder die Absicherung, wo man sagen kann, ja gut, wenn die...
Ist das die CSU-Klausel?
Nee, glaube ich nicht, weil die haben da doch eher andere Ergebnisse immer gehabt. Aber das heißt nur, dass die nicht die 5-Prozent-Hürde irgendwie scheuen müssen in Bayern, weil die halt eben immer genug Wahlkreise gewinnen, weil da gibt es eben keine andere große Partei.
Wie ist denn das überhaupt mit Parteien, die jetzt nur in einigen Ländern antreten? Also gerade diese CDU-CSU-Konstellation, also gelten die in irgendeiner Form als eine Partei, oder sind sie vollständig, was heißt die?
Die sind also vollständig getrennt. Das sind zwei getrennte Parteien. Und die CSU muss also in Bayern entweder ihre 5 Prozent, das schaffen sie auch, bzw. ihre drei Wahlkreise gewinnen, um im Bundestag zu sein.
Schaffen sie auch.
Das schaffen sie auch. Und an der Stelle braucht man dann bei der CSU keine Unterverteilung machen, weil die halt nur in Bayern antreten, also war nur der Rechenschritt, der da wegfällt. Und ansonsten tritt sozusagen rechnerisch die CSU dann gegen die CDU an.
Aber die verbünden sich dann sozusagen erst in Form einer Fraktion?
Genau, und im Bundestag setzen sich dann zusammen und machen eine Fraktion. Und da stänkert die SPD auch immer, dass das ja eigentlich gar nicht richtig ist. Und eigentlich ist ja auch die SPD die stärkste Fraktion. Aber die Spielchen machen die anderen halt eben auch, wo die sagen, die einen Zweitstimmen dürfen ja eigentlich gar nicht zählen, und dann sind wir doch stärker. Aber im Endeffekt heißt das nur, dass sie dann halt im Bundestag zusammenarbeiten.
Und wenn jetzt aber eine Partei in bestimmten Ländern nicht antritt, dann ist das sozusagen zu ihrem rechnerischen Nachteil?
Das ist zu ihrem rechnerischen Nachteil. Die muss dann natürlich in den Ländern, die sie dann antritt, dann immer noch entsprechend mehr Stimmen bekommen.
Das heißt, die 5 % gelten immer für die gesamte Bundesrepublik?
Es gibt Gelten für die ganze Bundesrepublik.
Nicht so, dass dann die Länder, wo man nicht antritt, einfach automatisch rausgerechnet werden, dass man nur in den Ländern...
Nein, nein, also es gilt nur in den Ländern... Es gilt also insgesamt die 5-Prozent-Hürde. Das heißt also, für die CSU ist das wirklich eine Hürde. Und für die CDU, naja, gut. Dass die da halt eben nur in 15 Ländern antreten.
Aber wenn jetzt so neue Parteien aufs Feld kommen, die noch nicht so verwendet werden... Auch die Linken mussten sich ja da erst mal versuchen, im Westen durchzuboxen. Die haben dann natürlich auch... Mit den Direktmandaten sind sie wahrscheinlich relativ sicher. Aber jetzt so eine neue Partei wie Piratenpartei zum Beispiel...
Für die gilt dann eben die 5-Prozent-Hürde auch. Wenn sie jetzt in irgendeinem Bundesland nicht antreten.
Okay.
Das war im Übrigen bei der allerersten Bundestagswahl anders. Da waren also wirklich die Bundesländer für sich getrennt. Und in jedem Bundesland wurde ein bestimmtes Kontingent an Sitze verteilt. Und da galt dann eben auch die 5-Prozent-Hürde nur in dem Bundesland und solche Sachen.
Gut, wie zählt man das jetzt aus? Also jetzt ist irgendwie abgestimmt worden, die Zettel liegen im Pott. Jetzt wird das alles zusammengetragen. Wie wird jetzt zum Ergebnis gekommen? Und wo entstehen da die Reibungen?
Ja, also das Ergebnis, also man zählt halt die Stimmen zusammen. In jedem Wahlkreis guckt man also nach, wie viele Erststimmen hat jetzt der Kandidat so zu bekommen. Dann kann man schon mal sagen, im Wahlkreis Joe, der ist gewählt. Und im zweiten Schritt guckt man dann also eben in den Wahlkreisen und dann in einem einzelnen Bundesland, wie viele Stimmen hat die Partei jetzt hier in diesem Bundesland bekommen. Und diese Ergebnisse werden dann eben zusammengefasst, weiter an den Bundeswahlleiter gegeben. Und der Bundeswahlleiter guckt dann erstmal nach, wie viele Stimmen hat jetzt jede Partei insgesamt bekommen. Und dann kann er auch schon mal sagen, wer jetzt über die 5% hörte, und wer nicht. So, und wenn er das gemacht hat, dann kann er schon mal sagen, so und so viel Prozent sind das. Das sind dann schon mal so und so viele Sitze. Das wird dann eben proportional ausgerechnet. Proportional nach diesen verschiedenen Verfahren, die es da in der Zeit bisher gab. Und im zweiten Schritt werden dann diese Sitze, die man da ausgerechnet hat, auf die Landeslisten, also auf die einzelnen Bundesländer wieder unterverteilt. So, dann weiß man, wie viele Sitze die Partei bekommt, bzw. der der einzelne Landesverband bekommt. Und zwar ist das dann eben auch grundsätzlich, was die Partei insgesamt bekommt. Das heißt, wenn jetzt irgendwie eine Partei in Nordrhein-Westfalen 30 Listensitze oder Sitze bekommt nach den Zweitstemmen, dann kriegt die Partei in diesem Land so viele Sitze, aber eben insgesamt. Dann guckt man sich an, wie viele Direktmandate hat sie bekommen. Dann sagt man, oh, die hat ja 20 Direktmandate bekommen. Dann bleiben eben nur noch 10 für die Liste übrig.
Das heißt, diese Betrachtung ist tatsächlich pro Land.
Die wird dann pro Land gemacht.
Das heißt, der erste Moment, wo wirklich Erststimme und Zweitstimme zusammentreffen, ist auf Landesebene. Man hat so und so viele Direktmandate innerhalb eines Bundeslandes, wenn es auch eine Bundestagswahl ist, und so und so viele Zweitstimmen. Und an der Stelle werden die zusammengeführt. Also nicht so, dass alles erstmal auf Bundesebene zusammengerechnet wird, sondern es wird jeweils auf Landesebene mit einem anderen Verband rechnet.
Ja, also die Direktmandate werden natürlich an der Stelle verrechnet, wo man sozusagen die Zweitstimmen erstmal oben auf der Bundesebene verrechnet hat und dann die Unterverteilung durchgeführt hat. Und das Ergebnis oder dieses Teilergebnis, was dann für eine Partei und ein Bundesland rausgekommen ist, an der Stelle findet dann die Verrechnung statt. Und an der Stelle entstehen natürlich dann die Überhangmandate, wenn das mit der Verrechnung nicht klappt.
Jetzt nochmal genau, also das Überhangmandat sagt was aus?
Das Überhangmandat sagt aus, wenn jetzt eine Partei in einem Bundesland mehr Direktmandate erhält, als ihr nach dem Zweitstimmen-Kontingent zustehen und nach der Rechnung, die wir gerade durchgeführt haben.
Dann wird das von der Liste abgezogen?
Ja, dann wird es von der Liste abgezogen, da die Liste aber zu klein ist und man nicht irgendwie negative Sitze noch dazuverteilen kann, darf sie also die Sitze, die sie dann direkt mehr gewonnen hat, auch behalten.
Das heißt, angenommen wir hätten jetzt eine Partei, die irgendwie, keine Ahnung, kriegt halt im Bundesland, was war dein Beispiel vorhin, 30% der Zweitstimmen? Nordrhein-Westfalen, wie viele Leute, weißt du das jetzt gerade auswendig, wenn man nur 30% Zweitstimmen in Nordrhein-Westfalen hätte, wie viele Listenplätze wären das so gefühlt? 5, 10, 20?
Keine Ahnung, sagen wir mal 20.
Gut, sagen wir mal 20.
Ist jetzt falsch, bitte keine Nachrechnung.
Irgendeine Zahl. So, und jetzt haben wir...
Zweifel viel mehr.
Wie viele Erststimmen?
Ja gut, die Erststimmen, da hängt es ja davon ab, wie es in einem einzelnen Wahlkreis aussieht. Das können mehr sein, das können weniger sein.
Ist da also wie viele Direktkandidaten?
Wenn es jetzt mehr sind, da ich jetzt 20 genommen habe, sage ich jetzt mal einfach 30. Die Partei hätte in dem Land 30 Direktmandate gewonnen. Nordrhein-Westfalen ist jetzt ein dummes Beispiel, weil da passiert sowas nicht.
Wir können auch ein Bundesland erfinden.
Ich meine, wir können jetzt einfach mal irgendwas Kleines nehmen. Bremen ist schön klein und übersichtlich.
Wir können auch gerne Bremen, das hat sie ja genauer angeschaut.
Die hatten also wenigstens 1994 die 3D-Wahlkreise. In Bremen gehen die Wahlkreise immer an die SPD. Nach den Zweitstimmen haben sie also zwei Sitze bekommen. Also ungefähr zweieinhalb wären das dann gewesen, aber das wurde dann in einem Fall abgerundet. Das heißt, die haben nach der Unterverteilung zwei Sitze bekommen. Das heißt, die kriegen dann diese drei Sitze, die dann von den Zweien abgezogen werden. Und das dann weniger ist als nichts, dürfen sie eben diese drei Mandate, die drei Direktmandate behalten.
Das heißt, eigentlich kommt niemand von der Liste rein?
Von der Liste kommt dann niemand rein.
Das heißt, wenn man in Bremen für die SPD antritt, dann muss man schon einen Wahlkreis haben sozusagen?
Dann muss man einen Wahlkreis haben.
Es sei denn, die Partei hätte noch sehr viel mehr Zweitstimmen bekommen, aber dann muss sie mindestens drei, mindestens vier haben, dass da sozusagen irgendjemand über die Liste reinkommt. Aber wenn es weniger ist, müsste ja eigentlich einer abgezogen werden, aber das wird nicht.
Genau.
Das heißt, deswegen kriegt die SPD einen Sitz mehr, als ihn über die Zweitstimmen eigentlich rechnerisch zustehen würde.
Genau, das ist dann das Überhangmandat, was dann damals in Bremen entstanden ist.
Jetzt ist gerade in der Diskussion, dass jetzt bei der nächsten Bundestagswahl die CDU besonders davon profitieren sollen würde. Worauf begründen sich diese Aussagen?
Ja, das liegt natürlich daran, welche Partei gewinnt die Direktmandate. Das ist natürlich immer die größte Partei oder eine Partei, die größer ist als die zweitstärkste. Das ist also in den meisten Bundesländern die CDU. Wenn die Partei jetzt aber deutlich unter 50 Prozent liegt, und das ist die CDU ja auch, dann entstehen also in der Regel Überhangmandate.
Das heißt also unter 50 Prozent der zweiten Stimmen?
Unter 50 Prozent der zweitstämmen.
Wovon eigentlich auszugehen ist, dass ihr das nicht schafft? Aber sie kriegt sozusagen 50 Prozent der Direktmandate?
Genau, dann kriege ich 100 Prozent der Direktmandate, die ja 50 Prozent von allen Mandaten dann ausmachen sollen.
Ich meine jetzt von allen, von den 299.
So und dann, wenn man jetzt, jetzt sagen wir mal Baden-Württemberg, wo das sehr wahrscheinlich eintritt, da kann man davon ausgehen, dass die CDU mehr oder weniger alle Wahlkreise gewinnt. Vielleicht ein oder zwei nicht, aber fast alle. So und wenn man dann sagt, okay, die werden dann irgendwie so um die 40 Prozent, lassen es 35, lassen es 45 sein, auf jeden Fall unter Prozent, unter 50 Prozent liegen. Und die SPD, die ist halt so niedrig, die gewinnt da irgendwie vielleicht einen Blumentopf. Ihre paar Prozent und vielleicht einen Wahlkreis. So und dann weiß man also, ja gut, in dem Bundesland kriegt dann eben die Partei, die CDU dann Überhangmandate. Und zwar umso mehr, je weniger Zweitstimmen sie da bekommt. Weil die Anzahl der Sitze ist mehr oder weniger dann eben festgelegt durch die Zahl der Wahlkreise, die sie da gewinnt. Und was jetzt bei Zweitstimmen rauskommt, ist für die Zahl der Sitze in Baden-Württemberg dann irrelevant.
Und damit ist es dann auch für die Zahl der Sitze im Bundestag eigentlich irrelevant, weil das ja quasi sich immer nur auf das Land bezieht. Also selbst wenn jetzt die Wähler, die CDU für irgendwas abstrafen wollen und sagen, ihr kriegt mal eine Zweitstimme nicht, aber sie wählen dann trotzdem ihren CDU-Wahlkreisabgeordneten direkt rein, dann betrifft die das Wort nicht.
Also wenn jetzt die Leute in Baden-Württemberg sozusagen nur mit der Erststimme die CDU wählen wollen, aber jetzt sagen, die Zweitstimmen, die kriegen die nicht, dann kriegt die CDU deutschlandweit mehr Sitze. Das hat was mit dem negativen Stimmgewicht zu tun und mit der Verrechnung mit den anderen Bundesländern. Das heißt also, wenn jetzt in Baden-Württemberg die CDU-Wähler alle sagen, okay, die Zweitstimme machen wir jetzt mal ungültig, aber die Wahlkreiskandidaten wählen trotzdem noch gut und wählen die, dann wird durch dieses geringere Gewicht von der CDU in Baden-Württemberg alle anderen Landesverbände gestärkt. Und dadurch erhält dann eben auch die CDU in Nordrhein-Westfalen ein paar Sitze mehr.
Warum werden die gestärkt?
Die werden dadurch gestärkt, dass eben insgesamt weniger Sitze zu verteilen sind. Und davon kriegt dann jeder was ab.
Weniger Sitze für Baden-Württemberg zu verteilen sind?
Genau. Die werden ja proportional nicht verteilt. Die Anzahl der Sitze steigt ja durch die Zahl der Überhangmandate. Und wenn jetzt die Leute halt eben nicht mehr die Zweitstimme der Partei geben, aber die erste Stimme wohl, dann ändert sich für das Bundesland erstmal gar nichts. Die kriegen genauso viele Sitze wie vorher. Aber das, was in Zweitstimmenkontingent dann sozusagen anders verteilt wird, das bekommen dann halt eben andere Landesverbände.
Das heißt, die beste Methode, die CDU zu wählen, ist sie nicht zu wählen?
Es ist zumindest eine Strategie. Man verschiebt in der Stelle natürlich auch die Oberverteilung. Also an die anderen Parteien fallen dann auch noch Sitze ab. Die beste Strategie ist wahrscheinlich, den gewünschten Koalitionspartner dann irgendwo zu wählen.
Das ist ja alles sehr verwirrend. Also da weiß man ja sozusagen überhaupt schon gar nicht mehr, was die eigene Stimme bewirkt. So ein bisschen. Das ist ja auch Kernpunkt deiner Beschwerde gewesen.
Genau, das ist also Kernpunkt der Beschwerde, dass man also eigentlich gar nicht mehr so richtig in die richtige Richtung wählt.
Jetzt gibt es ja diese verschiedenen Auszählungs- oder Sitzzuteilungsverfahren. Die haben wir jetzt immer nur so beiläufig erwähnt. Die haben drei schwerwiegende Namen mit irgendwie den Erfindern drin.
Das sind meistens gar nicht die Erfinder, sondern das sind meistens die, die das irgendwo propagiert haben. Oder das als Letzte auf den Tisch gelegt haben. Und bei denen ist dann meistens der Name hängen geblieben. Und meistens auch der im Land, der das gesagt hat. Also in einem anderen Land heißt das Verfahren dann auch manchmal anders. Das war dann am Anfang auch so ein bisschen verwirrend, wenn man dann geguckt hat, was haben die Amerikaner denn gemacht? Und die haben dann alle ihre eigenen Namen gehabt. Und bis man dann dahinter kommt, was das Jefferson-Verfahren auf der einen Seite, dann Tond-Verfahren bei uns heißt.
Verstehe, es gibt auch unterschiedliche Namen für dasselbe Verfahren. Aber welche Verfahren kommen denn jetzt zum Einsatz? Wir haben vorhin schon vorweg gegriffen, es wird sich was ändern. Das heißt, bisher kam dieses Herr Niemeier, sagt man?
Ja, Herr, weil das ein Engländer war, und Niemeier, das war ein Deutscher, die das vorgeschlagen hatten.
War das Politiker oder Mathematiker?
Ich glaube, Herr war Jurist und Niemeier, das war ein Mathematiker. Das Verfahren galt in Deutschland oder bei Bundestagswahlen seit 1987, glaube ich. Davor galt das Tond-Verfahren, das Höchstzahlverfahren nach Tond, das Diviso-Verfahren mit Abrundung. Ab der nächsten Bundestagswahl ist das dann das Diviso-Verfahren mit Standardrundung oder Saint-Laguer oder Websters.
Was besagt dieses Verfahren?
Die Verfahren, fangen wir mit dem Hennemeyer-Verfahren an. Besagen nur, wie man sitzeverteilt. Wenn man den Dreisatz rechnet, ist das nicht so, dass es dann ganz auskommt. Dann hat man irgendwie 87,3 Sitze. Das ist mit Leuten irgendwie unpraktisch. Dann muss man irgendwie runden. Wie rundet man das? Das ist das, was die Verfahren alle anders beantworten. Das ist das Herr Niemeyer-Verfahren. Das hat als Ansatz, dass man erstmal den Dreisatz rechnet. Wie viele Stimmen haben wir da zu berücksichtigen? Wie viele Sitze gibt es zu verteilen? Damit rechnet man das dann für jede Partei auf. Das ist die Sitze, die jede Partei bekommt. Und das, was nach dem Komma steht, da gucken wir, wie viele Sitze bleiben jetzt noch übrig. Und verteilen dann runter von der größten zum kleinsten Rest. Man nennt das auch manchmal Quotenverfahren nach größten Resten. Weil man hier die Quote ausrechnet und das dann nachverteilt. Das Verfahren hat einige Nachteile. Da gibt es verschiedene Paradoxien, so die Alabama-Paradoxen und noch ein paar andere, die da auftreten können oder die man beobachten kann. Das war auch einer der Gründe, warum das jetzt geändert wurde.
Und jetzt ist es geändert worden in das Sound-Aguille-Verfahren?
Genau, das ist das Divisor-Verfahren mit Standardrundung. Ein wesentlicher Grund, warum das auch geändert wurde, ist, dass man mehr oder weniger nicht sagen kann, was da überhaupt unterschiedliches rauskommt. Da kann nämlich keine Partei sagen, dass jetzt besser oder schlechter dadurch steht. Bei dem Divisor-Verfahren, das kann man so beschreiben, dass man sagt, ich nehme jetzt die Stimmen, die eine Partei bekommen hat, teile das durch irgendeinen Divisor, was weiß ich, 76.000 oder so, eine vernünftige Größenordnung. Und dann kommt dann irgendeine Sitzzahl raus, oder erstmal auch nur eine Bruchzahl, und die runde ich dann so, dass eben über 0,5 auf, unter 0,5 abgerundet wird. Macht das mit allen Parteien, mit dem gleichen Divisor natürlich.
Was sagt dieser Divisor aus?
Der Divisor, ne, das ist eigentlich eine Zahl, die dann sagt, für wie viele Stimmen gibt es einen Sitz.
Okay, also schon in etwa die Größenordnung.
Genau. Und der Divisor bestimmt sich dann mehr oder weniger so, dass am Ende die Sitzzahl, die man verteilen will, auch rauskommt.
Und orientiert sich natürlich an den wahlberechtigten mit dem Zeitalter abgegebenen Stimmen.
Genau. Und das ist halt eben die normale Rundung unter 0,5 und über 0,5. Dann wird jede Partei auch fair behandelt. So, ein ähnliches Verfahren, das war das Verfahren nach Tond. Das ist dann das Divisor-Verfahren mit Abrundung. Da geht man im Prinzip genauso ran, nur dass man eben nicht 0,5 rundet, sondern man rundet grundsätzlich ab. Das heißt also, man teilt durch ein Divisor, guckt, was dann rauskommt, und die Zahl, die rundet man dann nach unten ab.
Also de Hond, so de mit Hond. Genau. Was dann auch das Jefferson-Verfahren ist, was vorhin schon angesprochen hast.
Genau. Und das kennt man dann meistens auch irgendwie als Höchstzahlverfahren. Also die Divisor-Verfahren, die kann man dann mathematisch äquivalent auch anders beschreiben als Höchstzahlverfahren. Das hört sich dann ein bisschen einfacher an. Wenn man es dann tatsächlich durchführt, ist das natürlich bei vielen Sitzen schwierig. Man teilt die Stimmen, die eine Partei bekommen hat, erst durch eins, dann durch zwei, dann durch drei, dann durch vier, dann durch fünf und so weiter. Durch alle natürlichen Zahlen oder maximal bis zur Gesamtsitzzahl, dann kann man eigentlich immer aufhören. Und die größten Zahlen ordnet diese Ergebnisse nach der Größe und teilt entsprechend nach den größten Höchstzahlen die Sitze zu. Das ist also mathematisch äquivalent. Das kann man beim Songlary-Verfahren auch machen. Da hat man halt nicht die Divisor-Reihe eins, zwei, drei, sondern hat 0,5, 1,5, 2,5, was dann auch diese Rundung bei 0,5 andeutet.
Hat doch bestimmt mal jemand alle diese Verfahren genommen und alle Bundestagswahlen dagegen gerechnet, was für ein Ergebnis dabei rausgekommen wäre? Oder kann man das aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht machen?
Das kann man ganz bestimmt machen. Ich habe das jetzt nicht im Detail nachgerechnet, aber man kann sagen, was in der Tendenz rauskommt. Das Abrunden ist für die großen Einheiten günstiger. Wenn man jetzt eine großen Partei einen Nachkommateil wegnimmt, ist das natürlich etwas anderes, als wenn man jemanden, der bei 2 Kommen irgendwas liegt, den Nachkommateil wegschneidet.
Weil die Nachkommastelle proportional zu dem, was vor dem Komma steht, natürlich viel größeres Gewicht hat.
Genau. Deswegen ist das Verfahren nach der Rond günstig für die großen Parteien. Die kriegen dann immer mehr Sitze. Für die kleinen Parteien macht sich das immer dadurch bemerkbar, dass die im Zweifelsitz weniger bekommen.
Das wird also bei der nächsten Bundestagswahl anders gehandhabt. Man kann schon mal davon ausgehen, dass das reine Sitzzuteilungsverfahren sich etwas verbessert.
Ja, da gab es ja diesen Schritt über das Hennemeier-System, was ja auch irgendwo so rundet, wie man sich das vielleicht vorstellen könnte. Das heißt, viel wird sich an der Stelle nicht mehr ändern, nur dass da ein paar Paradoxien her, die eben nicht mehr auftreten können.
Also es hat vielleicht Einfluss auf einen Sitz, mehr oder weniger?
Das hat einen Einfluss auf einen Sitz. Das kann also dann Einfluss haben, wenn eine Partei irgendwo bei 0,5 oder in der Nähe liegt, dass da ein Sitz ein bisschen anders verteilt wird. Aber das kann man im Vorhinein, kann man das an der Stelle nicht sagen. Das hat also im Prinzip jetzt konkret für die Wähler keine Auswirkung, diese Änderung.
Aber im Zusammenhang mit diesem Herrn Niemeyer-Verfahren oder auch mit den anderen gibt es ja auch so eine Reihe von Paradoxons.
Genau, das Paradoxon, das heißt, dass man irgendwelche merkwürdigen Sprünge hat, wenn man am Wahlergebnis irgendwas ändert. Ein berühmtes Paradoxon ist dieses Alabama-Paradoxon. Alabama, da sind wir also schon in Amerika. In Amerika hat man dieses Verfahren benutzt, um die Sitze auf die einzelnen Bundesstaaten zu verteilen. Also man hat gesagt, der Kongress hat jetzt von mir aus 299 Sitze und dann verteilt man die einzelnen Sitze erstmal auf die Bundesstaaten, wo die Anzahl der Wahlkreise war. Und da kam dann bei einer Berechnung raus, ok, Alabama bekommt 8 Sitze, wenn wir als 299 Sitze insgesamt verteilen. So, und dann hat man noch ein paar andere Sachen mal ausgerechnet, was da so rauskommt. Wenn wir jetzt insgesamt 300 Sitze haben, dann bekommt Alabama plötzlich nur noch 7 Sitze. Das ist also das Alabama-Podroxan. An der Stelle ist das also aufgetreten und deswegen heißt das eben auch so.
Gut, das ist jetzt eine Schwäche, die das SaunaG-Verfahren so nicht hat?
Genau, das ist eine Schwäche, die alle Divisorverfahren nicht haben, weil die Divisorverfahren sozusagen Sitz für Sitz verteilen. Man kann also jeden Sitz sozusagen nummerieren. Die größte Partei bekommt den allerersten Sitz. Und dann, je nachdem, der zweite Sitz geht von mir aus an die zweitstärkste Partei oder wenn die erste doppelt so stark ist auch an die erste. Und entsprechend weiter. Und bei Behenemeyer geht das also nicht. Da kann es durchaus passieren, wenn man einen zusätzlichen Sitz verteilt, dass man dann sagen kann, oh, jetzt müssen wir irgendeinen Sitz abziehen. Und dafür kriegen dann andere zwei den Sitz. Das fällt natürlich nie auf, weil die Anzahl der Sitze, die man so verteilt bei der Bundestagswahl, ist halt fest. Deswegen ist es relativ unwahrscheinlich, dass man so etwas sieht. Aber jetzt bei der Bundestagswahl 1998 wurde das also wirklich noch mal beispielhaft nachgerechnet. Und da war also ein Sitz zwischen PDS und FDP relativ knapp. Und wenn man jetzt einfach sagt, wir hätten jetzt einen Sitz mehr proportional verteilt, dann hätte die PDS plötzlich einen Sitz weniger gekriegt.
Also wenn es einen weiteren im Bundestag gegeben hätte, der zu vergeben gewesen wäre.
Genau. Dann wäre dann plötzlich, hätte in dem größeren Parlament die PDS einen Sitz weniger gehabt.
Nur dadurch, dass mehr zur Verfügung stehen. Genau, das ist das Alabama-Paradoxon.
Dann gibt es noch ein paar andere Paradoxien, dass wenn man jetzt irgendwie einer dritten Partei noch Stimmen dazu gibt, dass dann plötzlich auch ein Sitz von einer Partei zur anderen rutscht, zwischen denen sich also nichts geändert hat. Das kann dann passieren, das ist dann auch ein anderes Paradoxon.
Das heißt, diese mathematischen Ausziehungsverfahren, da ist jetzt eine schrittweise Verbesserung vorgenommen worden. Und man kann jetzt sagen, mit diesem Saint-Laguay-Verfahren ist es jetzt zumindest schon mal so, dass diese ganz offensichtlichen Probleme wie das Donnverfahren, das jetzt einfach da mal so hinten abgeschnitten wird und dadurch sind große Zahlen bevorteilt gegenüber kleinen und dann auch große Parteien. Das ist jetzt erstmal weg. Das heißt, die eigentlichen Probleme, die du jetzt auch konkret mit dem Bundestagswahlrecht hast, bezieht sich im Wesentlichen auf diese negative Stimmverteilung bzw. die damit verbundenen Ausgleichs- und Überhangmandate. Oder gibt es noch andere wesentliche Kritikpunkte?
Also das ist der wesentliche Kritikpunkt, weil hier sozusagen das auch wirklich gezielt in die falsche Richtung läuft und nicht nur an irgendeiner Rundungsstelle in die falsche Richtung springt. Und die anderen Sachen, das sind eben mehr und mehr so Kleinigkeiten.
Aber das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat sich doch jetzt zu dieser Thematik auch noch ein weiteres Mal geäußert.
Genau, damit sind wir jetzt schon bei der nächsten, fast schon die übernächste Wahlprüfungsbeschwerde. Da gab es ja die Bundestagswahl 2002. Da kann ich jetzt noch mal ganz kurz durchgehen. Da hatte ich wohl einen Einspruch beim Bundestag eingelegt, einfach nur um zu dokumentieren, was da schiefgelaufen ist. Bin dann aber nicht weiter zum Bundesverfassungsgericht gegangen, einfach weil da hätte ich mir mehr oder weniger den Bedenkenbrief selber schreiben können. Dass ich doch schon mal keine vernünftige Antwort bekommen habe.
Der schon wieder.
Der schon wieder. Und dann gab es eine andere Wahlprüfungsbeschwerde und die habe ich dann unterstützt. Also auch eben ein bisschen Unterschriften gesammelt und selber unterschrieben und die sich auch gegen das negative Stimmgewicht gewandt hat. Das Interessante an der Stelle war, da gab es dann auch einen Bedenkenbrief, der da rausgekommen ist. Allerdings gab es keine Entscheidung. Das hat sich also hingezogen. Und es gab auch eine Stellungnahme von der CDU. Wo dann drin stand, also so eine mündliche Verhandlung, um das mit diesen bösen Überhangmandaten mal richtig zu klären, wäre eigentlich mal vernünftig. Das war ja auch die SPD-Überhangmandate 2002.
Also wo die SPD mehr bekommen hat als die CDU.
Genau. Und das mit der Entscheidung hat sich irgendwie verzögert. Und plötzlich kam, plötzlich unerwartet, die nächste Bundestagswahl. Eben ja vorher, weil der Bundestag aufgelöst wurde. Und das Verfahren wurde dann sozusagen nicht entschieden. Es wurde aber auch nicht nachher eingestellt, weil so eine Beschwerde gegen eine Bundestagswahl von einem Bundestag, der sozusagen schon wieder aufgelöst wurde, ist ja auch nicht mehr besonders sinnvoll. Da kann man dann auch sagen, okay, das hat sich jetzt erledigt. Haben die aber nicht gemacht. Inzwischen gibt es sogar, dieses Jahr gab es sogar eine Entscheidung, wo dann solche alten Fälle dann für erledigt geklärt wurden, wo man aber gesagt hat, aber wir behalten uns das Recht vor, auch so uralte Fälle dann.
Trotzdem noch zu leben, wenn wir der Meinung sind, das hätte irgendeine Relevanz.
Genau, wenn da irgendwie ein interessantes Thema ist, dann wollen wir uns das Recht behalten, da noch was zu sagen.
Das war dann offensichtlich ein interessantes Thema.
Das schien dann wohl doch ein interessantes Thema zu sein, wenigstens so interessant oder unklar, dass die Richter sich intern nicht einig waren. Wir hatten also den Verdacht, dass der Berichterstatter für Wahlrecht war, das war der Verfassungsrichter Jensch. Der schied dann irgendwann aus, 2005, dass man einfach warten wollte, bis der nicht mehr dabei ist, um das dann noch mal in Ruhe zu klären. Aber das ging dann halt nicht, weil eben vorher plötzlich eine neue Bundestagswahl stand. Und die Bundestagswahl war insoweit interessant, weil in einem Wahlkreis die Wahl sich verzögerte. In Dresden ist eine Kandidatin gestorben.
Die von der NPD?
Genau, von der NPD. Und zwar war das irgendwie drei Wochen vor der Bundestagswahl. Und das heißt, es war so kurzfristig, da konnte man nicht sagen, okay, die nominieren jetzt irgendwie einen nach und wir machen das einfach gleichzeitig.
Was sagt denn generell das Wahlrecht zu solchen Fällen?
Das Wahlrecht sagt, dann gibt es eine Nachwahl, was in diesem Fall Nachwahl heißt. Dann wird eben in dem Wahlkreis das ganze Prozedere nochmal neu aufgesetzt. Und die Partei, die...
Also mit neuen Kandidaten dann so?
Ja, beziehungsweise die Partei, die da ihren Kandidaten verloren hat, die kann dann eben nochmal...
Einen neuen bestimmen?
Kann dann nochmal neu bestimmen.
Das wird also später gewählt mit einem neuen Kandidaten, aber nicht zum gleichen Zeitpunkt?
Genau, nicht zum gleichen Zeitpunkt. Und die ganzen Briefwahlstimmen, die vielleicht schon unterwegs sind, die gehen also dann direkt in den Schredder. Die sind also ungültig. Und die werden dann eben neu verteilt ab dem Zeitpunkt, wo man das machen kann. Das ist auch schon mal vorher passiert. Allerdings war das dann eben nicht zwei, drei Wochen vorher, sondern eben schon anderthalb Monate. Und da konnte man dann eben noch mal in aller Ruhe das neu durchziehen. Das hat der Wähler eigentlich gar nicht gemerkt, dass dann plötzlich nicht mehr der Kandidat A, sondern der Kandidat A-Kandidiert ist.
Also es war ein totales Novum, sozusagen. Das erste Mal wirklich wegen Todesfall ein Wahlkreis später.
Das war ja wenigstens mit der Auswirkung, weil das ein Novum war. Was dann passiert? So, und das war dann auch noch nicht irgendwo in Deutschland, sondern auch in einem Bundesland, wo Überhangmandate zu erwarten waren. Nämlich in Sachsen, wo man davon ausgehen konnte, da kriegt die CDU bestimmt Überhangmandate. Weil in Sachsen, das ist also eben CDU-Land, da kriegt die SPD...
Also hohe Chance, Erstkandidaten, also Direktkandidaten durchzubekommen, aber wieder eine relativ niedrige Zweitstimmengeschichte.
Genau. Und für die Wähler der Nachwahl war das dann sogar so, die brauchten nicht mal über diese Abschätzung, die wir jetzt gemacht haben, ranzugehen, sondern die konnten einfach warten, bis die Hauptwahl durchwahl. Und dann wussten sie eigentlich ganz genau, wie es aussieht. Das sah dann halt eben so aus, dass die kritische Stimme irgendwo bei 42.000 lag. Also die CDU hatte, glaube ich, 13 Direktmandate schon gewonnen.
Also jetzt nochmal zur Logik. Also 13 Direktmandate in ganz Sachsen, weil man das ja auf Landesebene betrifft.
Genau, drei Direktmandate in ganz Sachsen.
So, das heißt, jetzt war es klar, umso mehr Zweitstimmen sie bekommen, umso größer die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass davon dann auch wieder welche weggehen.
Also, dass sie 13 Direktmandate bekommen. Sie hat 10 Listenmandate bekommen.
Nach den Zweitstimmen, wie sie bis dahin ausgezählt wurden.
Ja, abgegeben waren. Die in Dresden, die fehlten ja noch.
Das heißt, 10 minus 13 muss man ja rechnen.
Das sind minus drei, die werden nicht abgerechnet, das sind schon mal drei Übergangsmandate. Dann konnten zwei Sachen passieren. Das eine war, dass die CDU auch noch das Direktmandat in Dresden gewinnt, in dem Wahlkreis. Das wäre dann das 14. gewesen, was ja auch absehbar war. Was an der Stelle auch noch normal ist. Und man wusste, wenn wir jetzt aber zu viel Zweitstimmen haben, dann kriegt die CDU in Sachsen proportional 11 Sitze. Und dann wäre es wieder ein Überhangmandat weniger. Und das hätte natürlich passieren können.
Das heißt, dadurch, dass man jetzt in diesem Wahlkreis massiv CDU wählt, führt es sozusagen dazu, dass tatsächlich weniger Listenleute reinkommen.
Genau. Wenn die CDU also das Ergebnis gehabt hätte, was sie eben auch drei Jahre vorher bekommen hat, dann hätte sie einen Überhangmandat wieder abgeben müssen.
Das waren diese 42.000 Stimmen.
Genau. Und das waren diese 42.000 Stimmen. Das war dann sozusagen die Zahl, die wir in der Wahlnacht ausgerechnet haben.
Das heißt, konsequenterweise hätten eigentlich alle Parteien sozusagen dafür stimmen müssen, dass man die anderen wählt, um selber gewählt zu werden.
Genau. Also wenn jemand...
Wer auch immer da jetzt unmittelbar von profitiert hätte.
Wenn also wirklich jemand, der CDU dann Mandat abnehmen wollte, dann hätte er also in Dresden CDU wählen müssen.
Wenn jetzt alle... Das ist wahrscheinlich passiert, aber wenn jetzt alle in diesem Wahlkreis CDU gewählt hätten, also 100 Prozent der zwei Stimmen...
Ja, da hätte sich dann noch ein bisschen mehr verschoben, wenn das alle gemacht hätten. Also wenn alle SPD gewählt hätten, wäre sogar die SPD noch theoretisch an der CDU vorbeiziehen können. Das gabs, glaube ich. Oder hätten wirklich alle das machen müssen.
Aber wenn alle CDU gewählt hätten, wäre die CDU dadurch auch deutlich geschwächt worden?
Das muss man jetzt an der Stelle im Detail nachrechnen.
Aber es war offensichtlich, dass es eben die ganz bewusst bedeutete Mehrstimmen kann den ZEA bedeuten, weniger Sätze.
Genau. Das war dann eben auch genau an der Stelle, wo man so ad hoc auch gar nicht sagen konnte, in welche Richtung geht das denn. Also vorher waren irgendwie so über 50.000 Stimmen, die die CDU bekommen. Ich weiß jetzt nicht die genaue Zahl, ich sag mal 56.000. Und selbst wenn man sagt, okay, haben die es nun ein paar Prozent weniger gekriegt, das werden immer noch eine ganze Menge werden. Und 42.000 ist eher wenig. So und gut, am Ende waren es dann 38.000. Da gab es dann eben aber auch eine Aufklärungskampagne, wo also den Leuten gesagt wurde, was da rauskommt.
Jetzt wird uns bitte nicht sozusagen, das CDU hat explizit dafür geworben, nicht CDU zu werden.
Also die hat erstmal explizit darum geworben, dass es auf die Erststimme ankommt. Da gibt es also die Plakate, wo dann drauf steht, Erststimme CDU, der Herr Lämmel. Also das habe ich wenigstens nicht gefunden, dass die CDU da abgeraten hat, sich wegzunehmen. Also das glaube ich nicht, dass das auch diesmal passieren wird. Aber mit der Betonung auf der Erststimme, dass das wird dann bestimmt in den Ländern kommen. Die FDP hat sich natürlich gefreut. Und die hat dann wirklich dann plakatiert, Erststimme CDU und Zweitstimme FDP. Gut, das hat an der Stelle natürlich auch gut gewirkt. Das war dann wohl das beste Wahlergebnis, was die in irgendeinem Wahlkreis bekommen hatten. Und da sah man dann auch einen großen Unterschied zwischen dem, was dann als Briefweilergebnis reinkommt und was dann wirklich an der Urne gewählt wurde, wo die Leute dann sozusagen noch mal eine Woche mehr hatten, die Zeitung zu lesen und zu hören, was sich das da mit dem Wahlrecht auf sich hat.
Briefweilergebnisse werden tatsächlich auch explizit noch mal einzelnen... Ach, das ist ja ein eigener Wahlkreis.
Also kein eigener Wahlkreis, aber eigene Wahlbezirke.
Genau, Wahlbezirke.
Oder im Wahllokal, wo dann die Briefweiler ausgezählt werden.
Darin kann man dann die Unterschiede sehen.
So, und da kann man natürlich, man kann natürlich wahllokalerweise gucken, was da rausgekommen ist. Und da haben wir wirklich, in Dresden gibt es da also doch deutlich einen Unterschied. Also ich glaube, bei den Briefwählern hat die FDP 10% der Zweitstimmen und bei den Urnenwählern waren es dann aber schon 20% der Zweitstimmen.
Was war dann so die Folge davon? Von diesem Vorfall, der schön deutlich machte, was...
Ja gut, also erstens kam das Thema dann auch mal ein bisschen prominenter in der Presse. Und nicht nur einen Tag vor der Wahl und einen Tag nach der Wahl. Sondern das köchelte hier natürlich 14 Tage und vorher und nachher dann eben doch auch. Eben entsprechend, weil natürlich die Leute dann auch reagiert haben, weil die sozusagen erstmals mit so komischen Effekten im Wahlsystem sich auseinandersetzen konnten.
Du hattest dann wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen mehr Post als sonst.
Ja, und den einen oder anderen Anruf war schon interessant. Genau. Das war also die Geschichte um die Nachwahl drum herum. Und den Leuten ist eben auch klar geworden, irgendwas stimmt mit dem Wahlsystem nicht. Man kann also nicht einfach mal die Partei, die man gut findet, ankreuzen, sondern vielleicht muss man auch die Partei mal nicht ankreuzen, um sie zu unterstützen. So, und das war jetzt natürlich der Punkt, wo man das gesehen hat. Allerdings, weil bei der Wahlprüfung, bei dem Einspruch habe ich dann natürlich gesagt, dass ich jetzt nicht irgendwie dagegen bin, dass da irgendwo eine Nachwahl stattgefunden hat, sondern eigentlich nur, dass an der Stelle der Effekt aufgetreten ist, der ist aber auch woanders aufgetreten, der ist auch in Baden-Württemberg aufgetreten und in Brandenburg dann für die SPD und in ganzen Reihen von Bundesländern auch, wo dann Stimmen sich negativ für die gewählte Partei ausgewirkt haben. An der Stelle war es dann sozusagen für die Wähler vorher nur sicher, da gab es sozusagen die andere Alternative nicht.
Und wurde das jetzt vom Bundesverfassungsgericht nochmal aufgegriffen?
Genau, das ist im Prinzip das Verfahren erstmal genauso gelaufen. Also zuerst ein Einspruch beim Bundestag, der dann auch eben wieder mit Hinweis auf irgendwelche Sachen dann wieder abgelehnt wurde, dass gesagt, so schlimm ist das alles nicht.
Also war jetzt ein neuer Einspruch für die Wahl 2004?
Genau, 2005.
2005. Und die hat aber in dem Sinne dann keinen Bezug zu dem noch offenen Einspruch von der Wahl davor?
Nein. Also höchstens argumentativ, dass man da versucht hat, irgendwelche Punkte...
Ich frage nur, ob das irgendwie dann zusammengefasst werden kann oder wurde oder so. Also ich glaube, einen neuen Einspruch, der sich dann explizit wahrscheinlich auch mit diesem Vorfall in Sachsen dann aus dem Markt gesetzt hat.
Das war eigentlich nur eines der Beispiele.
Was es noch weitere gab.
Der Einspruch war inzwischen auch relativ kurz geworden, weil ich sozusagen nur noch die Beispiele aufgezählt habe und gesagt habe, wogegen das verstößt. Ich glaube, ich habe das inzwischen auf drei Seiten gekürzt. Ich meine, die wissen ja alles inzwischen schon. Ja, wie sie ja wissen.
Wurde sich denn da mehr darum gekümmert jetzt?
Eigentlich nicht.
Also haben sie auch noch keine Entscheidung?
Es gab keine Entscheidung. Der Bundestag lehnt das dann als offensichtlich unbegründet ab. Weil wenn es nur unbegründet ist, dann muss man vielleicht dummer darüber reden. Und das hat der Bundestag eigentlich nur nicht gemacht. Ist ja auch irgendwie Arbeit. Und gut, das Argument ist, ja gut, das fördert das Verfahren nicht. Und sollen die doch mal zum Verfassungsgericht gehen, dass die das klären. Das ist ja schon so lange genug. Also das dauert dann so knapp ein Jahr, bis der Bundestag durch ist. Und danach geht es eben wieder los. Wenn man zum Verfassungsgericht will, wegen einer Wahlbeschwerde, dann muss man eben 100 Wahlberechtigte finden, die einen da unterstützen. Das ging dann relativ schnell. Ich meine, die Internetseite hilft da so ein bisschen. Aber man muss dann trotzdem den einen oder anderen dann nochmal überzeugen. Und dann kam dann der Brief vom Verfassungsgericht, nachdem ich dann erstmal so die Unterschriften dahingeschickt habe und schon mal die ersten Unterlagen und gesagt, okay, ich leg hier eine Wahlbeschwerde ein. Dann kam dann plötzlich der erste Brief wieder, wo drin stand. Jo, sie müssen sich aber noch so ein bisschen mit der Argumentation des Bundestages auseinandersetzen.
Und wie war die?
Ja gut, die hatten jetzt nicht viel gesagt. Der Brief, der war dann auch sozusagen mehr oder weniger auch schon unterwegs. Aber dass das überhaupt so schnell kam, das fand ich jetzt schon ein gutes Zeichen. Ich weiß auch nicht, ob das vielleicht grundsätzlich so ist, dass das mehr oder weniger irgendwie auf der unteren Ebene läuft. Aber da hatte ich dann irgendwie doch den Eindruck, dass man sich da drum kümmert. Und dass man sich da vielleicht anders drum kümmert, als dass man es vielleicht vorher gemacht hatte. So, und dann passiert natürlich erstmal ja nichts. Und ja, Anfang letzten Jahres kam dann plötzlich ein Brief. Ja, der Bundestag hat ja jetzt das Wahlsystem geändert. Und hier das Ternemeyer-System ersetzt durch das Sonn-Lagü-System. Und hier dieser Effekt mit diesem negativen Stimmgewicht, kann das jetzt immer noch auftreten? Oder ist das jetzt nur für die letzte Bundestagswahl? Hat eigentlich nichts damit zu tun. Aber können Sie da vielleicht mal bis zum sonnsevielten März irgendwie was dazu schreiben?
Stellungnahme machen.
Genau. So, das fand ich ja schon mal gut. Weil wenn das nicht so wichtig ist, dann wäre das ja auch nicht so wichtig. Da hatte ich ja einen Anruf vom Bundesverfassungsgericht. Da war dann auch noch der Verfassungsrichter, Verfassungsrichter Mellumhoff, und der meinte, ja, wir machen jetzt mal ein mündliches Verfahren. Da war ich erstmal baff. Mündliche Verfahren gab es eigentlich noch nicht. Bei Wahlprüfungen. Da gab es eins mit den Überhangmandaten, also nicht mit den Überhangmandaten, sondern 1994 gab es also neben dieser Sache mit den Überhangmandaten was mit der Grundmandatklausel, wo die PDS mit reingekommen ist. Da gab es also ein mündliches Verfahren, was eben mit dieser Überhangmandategeschichte, was dann ein Normenkontrollverfahren, also das sozusagen Niedersachsen hat dann einfach mal das Verfassungsgericht eingerufen, zusammengelegt wurde. Das war ein Verfahren, was es schon mal gab. Und dann irgendwie so ganz Anfang der 50er, wo ein Abgeordneter in die DDR gezogen ist und dann plötzlich nicht mehr im Bundestag sitzen durfte, weil er nicht mehr wählbar war. Aber das waren sozusagen die einzigen Präzedenzfälle. Also sozusagen mehr oder weniger ganz ganz Neues. Der erste Punkt und der zweite Punkt ist, mündliche Verfahren, da braucht man einen Anwalt. Also normalerweise, wenn man eine Wahlprüfung machen will, dann kostet das viel Arbeit und eine Briefmarke. Man schreibt eben die Sache zusammen, muss dann noch die 100 Leute unterschreiben lassen, schickt das eben ans Verfassungsgericht oder vorher noch eine Briefmarke an den Bundestag. Und das ist es dann. Dann gibt es eine Entscheidung, in meisten Fällen negativ, von mir aus auch positiv, aber da entstehen nicht irgendwie großartige Kosten.
Aber mündliches Verfahren heißt ja dann konkret, es wird dann tatsächlich ein Termin einberufen, wo man hinkommt, Stellung gezielt. Und das bedeutet ja in der Regel auch, weil das ja wirklich für die wenigsten Einwände gemacht wird.
Das ist nicht völlig unbegründet.
Dann interessiert es das Gericht auch schon. Das war ja auch eine ähnliche Sache. Ich hatte ja hier vor einigen Ausgaben auch ein längeres Gespräch mit dem Ulrich Giesner gemacht, den ganzen Themenkomplex Wahlcomputer. Auch da meinte er ja genau diese Aufmerksamkeit, die einem da auf einmal zukommt, da merkt man dann schon, das ist ein Thema, das denen auch wichtig ist. Und das ist jetzt hier wahrscheinlich ähnlich.
Genau, das war ähnlich. Das war an der Stelle eben nur vorher. Ulrich konnte sich ja so ein bisschen auf unsere Erfahrungen da auch stützen. Stützen, wie das Ablauf laufen kann, wie das passiert. Wobei natürlich Ulrich dann direkt mit Anwalt rangegangen ist. Er hat also dann schon in den Einspruch oder in die Beschwerde mehr Aufwand gelegt.
Aber für dich war das jetzt sozusagen was Neues?
So, an der Stelle war das erstmal was Neues.
Aber du hast auch einen passenden Anwalt gefunden?
Ja, vor allem das Interessante war, das wurde mir auch direkt empfohlen.
Ach wirklich?
Der Verfassungsrichter meinte, ja. Also da kennt sich der Prof. Mayer aus Berlin, der kennt sich mit dem Thema aus. Prof. Mayer wäre mehr oder weniger auch die erste Wahl gewesen. Der hatte also bei dem Verfahren mit den Überhangmandaten das Land Niedersachsen beim Bundesverfassungsgericht vertreten. Und er hatte also auch die erste Veröffentlichung gemacht, wo das negative Stimmgewicht als ein Beispiel erwähnt worden ist. Wo er also gesagt hat, ich weiß nicht, ob das das Brems-Klops war, ein anderes Beispiel, aber wo er gesagt hat, ja, das ist also an der Stelle schon völlig unsinnig, ist aber auch nicht weiter auf das negative Stimmgewicht eingegangen, sondern hat gesagt, die Überhangmandate als solche sind böse. Und an der Stelle, das ist ja der Ansatz, den wir da völlig versucht haben zu vermeiden, sondern wir haben gesagt, die Überhangmandate, da sangen wir nichts gegen, aber wenn man mehr Sitze bekommt, weil man weniger Stimmen bekommt, dann kann das eigentlich nicht sein. Und dann hatten wir es Professor Mayer gefragt und er wollte das auch machen. Ah nee, Mellinghoff hat sogar gesagt, ja meine Kollegin hat auch mal angerufen und der ist grundsätzlich bereit, das zu machen. Das ist natürlich auch ein zweites Indiz, dass sie das auch wirklich ordentlich durchziehen wollen und das wieder mit einem vernünftigen Anwalt, der sich da im Thema auskennt.
Also sie wollten das tatsächlich einfach behandeln?
Die wollten das behandeln und die wollten das durchziehen. Das macht schon.
Waren sie sozusagen auf die Flanke im Strafraum?
Genau, das sah also schon sehr gut aus an der Stelle. Gut und dann war eben die mündliche Verhandlung im April. Im April war das.
Im April welchen Jahres?
2008 letztes Jahr. Ja, dann sitzen wir dann erstmal auf Verfassungsgericht. Da hatten wir uns erstmal vom Mittagsnummer zusammengesetzt. Das war also nur in der Mittags. Die Punkte nochmal durchgegangen. Ja und dann war eben die Verhandlung. Ist natürlich erstmal auch großartiges Ereignis. Auf der Gegenseite war dann zwei Abgeordnete des Bundestages aus dem Wahlprüfungsausschuss. Also der Abgeordnete Strobl, der Vorsitzender von der CDU, und von der SPD Abgeordnete Dressel, stellvertretende Wahlprüfungsvorsitzende. Und dann noch als Vertreter Professor Lang aus Rostock, der dann sozusagen der Prozessbevollmächtigte für den Bundestag war. So und von den Parteien hatte die CDU dann noch einen Vertreter dahingeschickt, die SPD noch Beobachter, die da nichts gesagt hatten und die anderen Parteien dann eigentlich nicht. Das waren dann die Beteiligten. Das ist dann noch so übersichtlich, wenn man das mit anderen Verfahren vergleicht, wo dann die Richter irgendwie so eine halbe Stunde erstmal sagen, wer überhaupt gekommen ist.
Aber was war denn dann deren Argumentation? Also inwiefern hat ihr denn jetzt...
Also die Argumentation ist im Wesentlichen, ja, das ist alles nicht so schlimm und...
Kann man sich mit wichtigen Sachen beschäftigen und überhaupt.
Genau und selbst wenn das so schlimm ist, dann kann man eigentlich jetzt an diesen Bundestag nicht dran gehen und auflösen soll man den eigentlich auch nicht. So ein ganz klein bisschen Angst hatten sie da auch. Also nicht allzu große.
Aber man weiß ja nie.
Man weiß ja nie und genau. Ein Argument von der SPD war dann auch, dass bei diesen Lösungsmöglichkeiten, da gibt es ja auch so viele, und die CSU, die ja nur in Bayern antritt, wo man eigentlich nicht so richtig verrechnen kann, da gibt es dann... Also da haben wir ein Problem mit. Das kann man ja auch nachvollziehen. Ja, das waren dann die Argumente, aber so richtig sauber argumentiert geht an der Stelle nicht.
Die SPD hat gesagt, das einzige Problem, womit sie haben, ist ein Wahlrecht, das die CSU in den Bundestag bringt, oder wie?
Nein, also als Möglichkeit, wie man das negative Stimmgewicht ausschalten kann, gibt es also ein Modell, was Professor Pucklsheim, der als Sachverständiger geladen wurde, sozusagen mehr oder weniger der einzige Mathematiker, der sich in Deutschland um das Thema kümmert, der hat gesagt, ja, eine Möglichkeit ist eben sozusagen eine Methode, wo man das kompensiert. Das ist dann die direktmandatsbedingte Divisor-Methode. Kannte er das? Das heißt im Wesentlichen, man macht die Verrechnung einen Schritt vorher. Man guckt sich eben an, wie viele Sitze bekommt jetzt die SPD in ganz Deutschland.
Und das bestimmt dann sozusagen den Divisor für die eigentliche Sitzverteilung?
Ja, man macht an der Stelle die Verrechnung mit den Direktmandaten. Man macht das nicht mehr auf Landesebene, sondern man macht das auf Bundesebene. Man guckt sich dann an, okay, so und so viele Mandate bleiben übrig. Und die verteilt man dann irgendwie unter, dass es mehr oder weniger so ähnlich aussieht, wie jetzt auch, eben nur, dass keine Überhangmandate und negative Stimmgewichte mehr entstehen können. So, und an der Stelle, wo eine Partei nur in einem Bundesland antritt, geht das nicht, weil da ist man automatisch auf der oberen Ebene. So, das ist eben auch ein Problem, was man an der Stelle hat. Da kommt man dann sozusagen nicht dran vorbei, irgendeine andere Entscheidung zu treffen. Dass man eben sagt, okay, die Überhangmandate, die führen jetzt nicht zu negativen Stimmgewichten, die kann man akzeptieren. Oder man wird ganz drastisch und sagt, ja gut, dann muss man halt eben irgendeinen Direktmandat streichen oder irgendwie anders verteilen. Was aber etwas ist, was man jetzt wirklich nicht machen will, weil man sagt, okay, das kann man jetzt im Wahlkreis nun wirklich nicht vermitteln, dass wir sagen, okay, der hat wohl die meisten Stimmen bekommen, aber der soll dann doch nicht rein. Also das...
Ja, das geht ja nicht, weil dann würde sich der Wahlkreis überhaupt nicht mehr vertreten fühlen.
Ja, genau. Also es wäre möglich, wäre sogar verfassungsgemäß, weil in Bayern gab es immer so eine Möglichkeit, mit überhangenden Mandaten herzuwerden. Die hatten also wirklich jede Methode, die man da machen kann. Gab es da schon mal. Aber das ist halt nichts, was man will. Deswegen ist das halt eben ein Problem von der Methode. Aber gut, das wurde dann sozusagen als eine Lösung vorgestellt. Dann gab es natürlich noch viele andere Methoden, Möglichkeiten, wie man das negative Stimmgewicht vermeiden kann. Also man könnte sagen, okay, wir machen jetzt eigentlich direkt Mehrheitswahl oder man macht ein Grabenwahlrecht, dass man sagt, okay, wir machen überhaupt gar keine Rechnung mehr.
Ein Grabenwahlrecht?
Genau, Grabenwahlrecht ist eine…
Das heißt, wer zu viel Stimmen kriegt, der kommt in den Graben?
Nee, das ist sozusagen ein Graben, der dann sozusagen durch den Bundestag geht und die Proporz- und Mehrheitswahlabgeordneten trennt. Was dann auch gescheitert ist, weil das dann den Graben durch die Koalition gezogen hätte, weil dann die kleinen Parteien verlieren. Ein Grabenwahlsystem ist, man wählt die Hälfte der Abgeordneten über eine Mehrheitswahl und die Hälfte der Abgeordneten über eine Listenwahl und es gibt keine Verrechnung dazwischen. Das heißt also, klare Trennung. 299 Abgeordnete werden nach Proporz gewählt und 299 Abgeordnete werden nach Mehrheitswahl gewählt.
Dann sind es halt so viele, wie es sind.
Genau, dann kann sowas auch gar nicht mehr auftreten. Weil in seinem System passt dann eben alles. So, das ist eine Möglichkeit. Ich meine, über sowas wird man in den 60er-Jahren nachgedacht. Aber das wird dann eben auch nicht eingeführt.
Was ist denn jetzt so euer Standpunkt gewesen? Ich meine, wenn ihr jetzt beim Bundesverfassungsgericht auftaucht und sagt, sonst passt das nicht, wie es läuft, dann müsste ja im Prinzip auch mit irgendeiner Alternative am Start sein.
Ja gut, man muss wenigstens eine Alternative bieten, wo man sagt, die ist besser. Und das ist eigentlich nach unserer Einschätzung eben auch, dass in dieser Derik Mandats bedingt die Visa-Methode, wie Professor Puckelsheim das genannt hatte, oder eben auch in interne Kompensationen, wie das, glaube ich, mal vom Innenministerium genannt wurde, als diese Modelle in den 90ern entwickelt hatten. Da gab es dann auch einen Gesetzentwurf der Grünen zu, der sowas in der Art geregelt hätte. jetzt gab es ja auch einen Gesetzentwurf, der dann letzte Woche dann gescheitert ist. Im Bundestag.
Von den Grünen?
Genau. Aber das ist eben eine Möglichkeit, wie man es hätte machen können. Wir haben natürlich gesagt, es gibt auch andere Möglichkeiten, wie man das machen kann. Man kann ja jetzt irgendwie ganz mathematisch rangehen und sagen, wenn eine Partei für mehr Stimmen weniger Sitze bekommt, dann soll sie doch die weniger Sitzen bekommen. Es ist allerdings schwer, so etwas als mathematisches Prinzip dann in Paragrafen zu gießen. Oder irgendwie anders rechnen, dass man sagt, die Bundesländer sind jetzt getrennt und wir machen jetzt in jedem Bundesland die eigene Sitzverteilung, ohne dass es eine Verrechnung über die Länder gibt. Dann kann sowas auch nicht auftreten.
Aber so richtig festgelegt habt ihr euch jetzt nicht?
Nein, wir haben festgelegt, müssen wir ja nicht. Das ist im Endeffekt der Bundestag, der sagen muss, wie es aussehen soll. Wir haben eben nur gesagt, das eine ist wohl die vernünftigste Art, weil man da auch relativ wenig ins Gesetz eingreifen muss. Man ändert also nicht das Gesetz als Ganzes, die Struktur, sondern man ändert eigentlich nur was an einem Berechnungsschema.
Und was war dann die Entscheidung des Bundesverfassungsgerichts?
Das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat dann eben gesagt, dass das mit der Unmittelbarkeit und Gleichheit, die wir ja nicht angesprochen hatten, nicht vereinbar ist, dass das Gesetz geändert werden muss. Aber erst 2011. Das heißt, explizit wurde eben gesagt, bei der nächsten Bundestagswahl ist das dann doch nicht so schlimm.
Aber der nächste Bundestag muss sich eigentlich zwangsläufig mit diesem Thema beschäftigen, wenn er dann nochmal gewählt werden möchte.
Genau. Das ist natürlich eine blöde Sache. Wir können natürlich sagen, an der Stelle hat das Verfassungsgericht wirklich einen Fehler gemacht, weil die den Effekt auch unterschätzt haben. Weil die gesagt haben, man kann es eigentlich vorher nicht wissen, was so nicht stimmt, weil den Effekt und die Größenordnung des Effektes. Also man kann vorher wissen, wo über Hangmandate auftreten und man kann auch sein Stimmverhalten entsprechend ausrichten.
Diese Betrachtung, die jetzt für die nächste Bundestagswahl, was wir schon angesprochen haben, wo im Wesentlichen CDU bevorteilt werden würde, welche Dimensionen kann das annehmen, deiner Meinung nach? Wie viele Sitze reden wir?
Wir reden von 20 bis 100 Sitze.
20 bis 100 Sitze?
Genau. Das hängt davon ab, wie die Wähler reagieren. Wenn die Wähler jetzt so reagieren, da gab es ja jetzt letzte Woche so eine Modellrechnung, wo man gesagt hat, okay, wir nehmen jetzt mal so die die Größenordnung, was die Umfragen jetzt sagen, und machen daraus mal so eine Hochrechnung auf die einzelnen Länder und sagen, im Großen und Ganzen wählen die dann eben so wie damals, eben nur, dass man die Verschiebung einberechnet. Dann kommt man auf eine Größenordnung von 20 Überhangmandaten. 20 bis 25 oder so stehen, glaube ich, im Spiegel.
Pro CDU, nur CDU.
Ja, ein paar, irgendwie so zwei oder drei gehen dann an die SPD.
Aber auch nur entweder die einen oder die anderen. Also eigentlich nur diejenigen, die halt wirklich in Wahlkreisen einfach eine Chance haben. Also könnte ja rein theoretisch auch die SPD betreffen mit ihren Direktmandaten. Die kriegt halt mehr Zweitstimmen als...
Die kriegt vielleicht eine Anfall Direktmandate, aber nicht so, dass es Überhangmandate wären.
20 bis 25, da gibt es ja Parteien, die werden schon ganz froh, wenn sie überhaupt so eine Fraktion stehen.
Das ist erstmal eine Größenordnung, wo man sagt, wenn die Leute so wählen, wie sie das letzte Mal gemacht haben. Wenn man jetzt sagt, die Wähler reagieren jetzt darauf, so ähnlich wie in Dresden, dann wären es natürlich mehr. Dann kann man schon sagen, ja gut, dann wären natürlich ganz viele Leute wie in Dresden sagen, okay, wenn ich die CDU mit meiner Zweitstimme nicht unterstütze, sondern es schadet, dann werde ich doch vielleicht lieber FDP. Das ist ja irgendwie naheliegend. Und wenn das ähnlich wie in Dresden passiert, dann...
Das heißt, man würde sozusagen mit seiner Stimme eigentlich zwei Parteien auf einmal wählen. Man würde einerseits der CDU weniger Abzug zuführen, als auch der FDP noch eine weitere Stimme.
Genau, sozusagen das doppelte Stimmgewicht, was ja schon vorher an Überhangmandaten kritisiert wurde. Aber wenn das so ähnlich läuft, dann könnten da 40 Überhangmandate rauskriegen. Das ist krass. Ja, und die 100, das ist jetzt mal so Pi mal Daumen, wenn das sozusagen alle in allen Bundesländern machen, wo Überhangmandate auftreten, dann kommt man in diese Größenordnung von 100.
Aber dann müsste man das Ganze sozusagen mathematisch voll im Griff haben, im Prinzip genau vorher wissen.
Ne, ne, braucht man nicht. Man muss eigentlich nur wissen, wo treten Überhangmandate auf? Und wenn man jetzt bei der letzten Bundestagswahl alle Länder, wo Überhangmandate aufgetreten sind, plus die, wo der Überhang sozusagen bei 0 war, also sozusagen kein Listenmandat verteilt wurde, was dann sozusagen dann im Nachkommenbereich der Überhangen ist, wenn in diesen Ländern jetzt die Wähler alle so reagiert hätten, dass die die schädliche Stimme verabscheut hätten und das nicht gemacht hätten, dann wären ja sozusagen alle Direktmandate, die da gewonnen wurden, Überhangmandate automatisch und dann wären da 87 Stück. So und bei der nächsten Bundestagswahl wird sich bei einigen Bundesländern was ändern. Auch mit der Partei wird sich ein bisschen ändern, aber so als Größenordnung wird wahrscheinlich nicht rauskommen in der Größenordnung.
Aber das ist ja nicht ganz insignifikant, meine ich.
Das ist...
Das sind knapp 700 Abgeordneten.
Ja, das ist...
Das spielt schon eine Rolle.
600.
Genau. Und zweifel mehr. Also 580. Sogar, ja, genau. Ja gut, so viel wären es nicht.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall jetzt keine Größenordnung, wo man sagen würde, ach, pfff. Sondern das ist schon dignifikan.
Ist schon was.
Ich meine, wenn man sich gerade die Kräfte-Verhältnisse derzeit anschaut zwischen SPD und CDU.
Ist ja auch das, was jetzt die letzten Wochen, also den Streit in die Koalition reingetragen hat, dass die SPD irgendwo begriffen hat, dass sie diesmal von den Wagenmandaten eben nicht profitieren wird.
Aber auch nicht mit einer Änderung dieses Gesetzes forstiert hat.
Ja gut, sie haben es versucht. Wenigstens so ein bisschen. Und die CDU hat natürlich begriffen, dass ihr das natürlich für die Mehrheit dann noch mal so einen kleinen Zuschlag bringt. Das erklärt natürlich auch an der Stelle die Haltung, dass das jetzt mit Ändern jetzt also mal nicht übers Knie gebrochen werden soll.
Mit welcher Mehrheit muss denn das geändert werden? Reicht das eine normale Parlamentsmehrheit?
Das ist eine normale Mehrheit, also einfache Mehrheit. Das heißt, wenn dann festgestellt worden wäre, jo, die Mehrheit hat jetzt dafür gestimmt, dann wäre das halt durchgegangen.
Das heißt, man kann jetzt davon ausgehen, dass die CDU dann ohne die SPD entscheiden kann in der nächsten Legislaturperiode, wie man das so ändert?
Es wird wenigstens wahrscheinlicher dadurch. Das ist vielleicht noch nicht sicher, aber eben die Umfragen sagen ja so, dass irgendwie so die CDU und die FDP zusammen so gerade um die 50 Prozent sein könnten. Mit Überhangmandaten sind sie vielleicht etwas sicherer drin. Oder vielleicht eben gerade deswegen.
Das mit dem Wählen, das ist nicht so einfach. Wie machen denn die anderen Länder das? Also wenn man jetzt mal den Blick von Deutschland wegnimmt, andere Länder, andere Sitten und vor allem auch andere Wahlsysteme. Als erstes Beispiel in Europa dürfte einem natürlich immer gleich in Britannien einfallen, wo das Mehrheitswahlrecht auch das Grundprinzip ist. Da hat man quasi nur Direktmandate bzw. nur ein Mehrheitswahlrecht.
Genau. Also in Großbritannien ist das eben relativ einfach. Wobei ich immer einfach sage, so einen Wahlkreis zu zeichnen, ist das nicht einfach. Aber für die Wähler ist es insofern einfach, dass das Land eben in 600 Wahlkreise eingeteilt ist. Und gewonnen hat der, der die meisten Stimmen hat.
In den jeweiligen Wahlkreisen?
In den jeweiligen Wahlkreisen.
Es gibt keinerlei Übertrag von den einen auf den anderen.
Genau. So ist das halt in Großbritannien. So ist das auch in Vereinigten Staaten. Wobei in Großbritannien sich interessanterweise da nicht ein krasses Zwei-Parteien-Wahlsystem rauskristallisiert hat, sondern da gibt es dann eben trotzdem noch drei oder mehr Parteien, die da Chancen haben, Sitze zu bekommen.
Was aber auch durch die große Diversität innerhalb Großbritanniens mit beeinflusst ist, also Schottland sozusagen, die ja auch komplett andere...
Ja gut, da kommen dann natürlich noch irgendwie schottische Nationalpartei dazu, die da irgendwie anders auftritt. Aber da gibt es dann auch wirklich viele Wahlkreise, wo dann irgendwie so drei Kandidaten sind, die irgendwo ein Drittel der Stimmen bekommen. Und der, der am meisten bekommt, der hat dann eben den Wahlkreis gewonnen.
Das ist auch nicht umstritten, das Wahlsystem in Britannien, oder?
Doch, das ist immer umstritten. Und da kommen dann auch immer Forderungen raus. Man soll doch irgendwo mal ein Verhältniswahlsystem einführen. Oder irgendwas, was in die Richtung von Verhältniswahlsystem geht. Da gab es in den 90ern auch so eine Kommission, die Jenkins-Kommission, die da einen Vorschlag gemacht hat, wie man sowas implementieren könnte, ohne dass man dann gleich die Wahlkreise alle abschafft. Und bei internen Wahlsystemen, also beim schottischen Parlament und bei der Welsh Assembly und auch bei dieser London Assembly, sind auch so Verhältniswahlsysteme eingeführt worden, wo man dann sozusagen die Direktmandate so ähnlich wie in Deutschland verrechnet. Allerdings dann ohne negative Stimmgewichte. Aber es ist natürlich immer so, dass die Partei, die gerade an der Macht ist, die profitiert halt eben von dem System, nachdem sie gewählt worden ist. Und die hat natürlich immer das geringste Interesse, an der Stelle was zu ändern. Und deswegen haben Wahlsysteme natürlich irgendwo so die Eigenschaft, so zu bleiben, wie sie gerade sind.
Weil du jetzt sonst so in Europa aus?
Ja gut, in Frankreich gibt es auch dieses Mehrheitswahlsystem. Allerdings gibt es da das absolute Mehrheitswahlsystem, was in Großbritannien das Relative Mehrheitswahlsystem ist. Das heißt, wenn man im ersten Wahlgang nicht die 50 Prozent der Wähler hinter sich hat, dann muss man in den Stichwahlen. Während es das eben in Großbritannien nicht gibt. So und die anderen, die haben im Wesentlichen irgendwelche Verhältniswahlsysteme, die dann mehr oder weniger kompliziert aussehen, das ist, ich habe mich auch nicht in alle ganz tief reingesetzt, das ist mehr oder weniger, wie es sich gerade ergibt oder ob da irgendwo gerade etwas Interessantes ist, was man da beobachten kann.
Wie ist das denn überhaupt mit der Europawahl? Welche Wahlsysteme, also, gelten denn bei einer?
Bei der Europawahl gibt es inzwischen die Vorschrift, dass da nach Verhältniswahl grundsätzlich gewählt werden soll. Das heißt, an der Stelle haben alle Länder irgendwelche Verhältniswahlsysteme oder so ähnliche Systeme eingeführt. Das heißt also, eben auch in Großbritannien können an der Stelle dann eben kleine Parteien antreten und haben Chance, Sitze zu bekommen, weil man da eben in einem großen Wahlkreis, der da irgendwie, ich sag mal, halb England ist oder Schottland oder ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie groß da die Wahlkreise sind, wo dann proportional gewählt wird. So ähnliche Systeme haben dann sozusagen alle Länder. Also entweder reine Verhältniswahl, wie wir es bei uns haben, dann allerdings mit 5%-Hürde.
Also gibt es diese Hürde jetzt europaeinheitlich? Also gibt es in irgendeiner Form einheitliches Europawahlrecht?
Nein, es gibt kein einheitliches Europawahlrecht, sondern das regelt jedes Land für sich. Aber es gibt eben schon diesen Grundsatz, der der Verhältniswahl soll sozusagen in jedem Land gelten.
Das heißt, die Verhältniswahl ist eigentlich schon das dominante Wahlrecht, wenn man es jetzt mal so sieht?
Genau.
Auch wenn es jetzt in Britannien und USA anders ist.
Für das nationale Parlament dann. Ja gut, man kann natürlich dann auch noch sagen, so richtig verhältnisweite ist die Europawahl schon deswegen nicht, weil die Länder ja unterschiedlich gewichtet werden. Das heißt also, Malta hat irgendwo ein anderes Gewicht als Deutschland schon allein wegen der Größe da haben. Also die kleinen Länder dann halt einen Vorteil.
Was sind denn so deine Vorstellungen, wohin sich das entwickeln soll? Ist das eigentlich jetzt eigentlich alles so ganz gerecht und man muss jetzt nur ein paar Stellschrauben drehen oder gibt es auch so generelle Erwägungen, wie man Wahlen machen kann, wohin sich das so entwickeln sollte oder könnte?
Ja, das ist jetzt natürlich ein anderer Punkt. Wenn man sagt, wie soll es sein, gibt man ja sozusagen irgendwo was vor. Das ist natürlich jetzt schwieriger, als wenn man sagt, okay, jetzt hier ist ein Fehler, so darf es auf keinen Fall sein. Das sind ja die Sachen, die wir dokumentieren und versuchen, darauf hinzuweisen. Bei den anderen Sachen, da muss man natürlich immer gucken und abwägen.
Also Wahlrechte versteht euch da eher als Bugtracker sozusagen. Hier ist jetzt ein explizites Problem, dem müssen wir jetzt mal beigehen.
Ich meine, man kann jetzt natürlich sagen, was kann man denn machen? Man kann jetzt hier mehr Einfluss der Wähler einführen, welche Personen denn gewählt werden sollen.
Da gibt es jetzt zum Beispiel so Initiativen wie Mehr Demokratie e.V., die explizit jetzt auf diese Listen Einfluss nehmen wollen.
Genau, da gab es ja in Nordrhein-Westfalen einen Versuch, das Wahlgesetz zu ändern, wo man gesagt hat, okay, wir wollen jetzt hier kommunalieren und panaschieren. Das heißt, wir wollen nicht nur eine Partei wählen, sondern wir wollen auch Personen wählen. Und da kann man dann eben nicht nur eine Partei einkreuzen, sondern man kann sagen, okay, hier der Kandidat Sonso, der soll in den Stadtrat gewählt werden und deswegen kreuze ich den jetzt an. Und da gibt es halt dieses System mit dem kumulieren, das heißt, der kriegt eben nicht nur eine Stimme, sondern er kriegt mehrere Stimmen. In dem Fall dann konkret bis zu drei. Und panaschieren heißt, okay, ich bin jetzt eigentlich hier für die Partei A, aber der Kandidat Sonso von Partei B, der ist eigentlich auch ganz gut und der kriegt jetzt auch eine Stimme von mir. Das ist dieses Panaschieren. Das ist eine Möglichkeit, wie man das machen kann, was es auch in vielen Bundesländern für Kommunalwahlen auch gibt. In Nordrhein-Westfalen gibt es das halt eben noch nicht.
Wäre das auch ein Modell für die Bundestagswahlen? Oder ist überhaupt belegt, dass das was bringt, dass das überhaupt zum Einsatz kommt?
Ja gut, es gibt eben entsprechend viele Leute, die sich das eben angucken und sagen, ok, der hat was gemacht und den Kandidaten will ich nicht drin haben. Und das hat eben einen gewissen Einfluss. Andere sagen halt, ich kenne die Leute nicht, ich mache nur oben ein Kreuzchen bei der Partei, die ich immer wähle und dann wird das schon richtig verteilt.
Man hat also sozusagen beide Möglichkeiten.
Das gibt es.
Bisher aber auch anders.
Genau, das sind da die Möglichkeiten. Das ist eben eine Möglichkeit. Ich meine, muss man an der Stelle auch sagen, Nachteil von dem System ist, dass das Auszählen schwieriger wird. Das ist an der Stelle, wo sich die Wahlcomputerhersteller gefreut haben. Das ist ein Grund für Wahlcomputer. Dann kann man trotzdem schnell auszählen. Geht aber auch so. Das ist jetzt also noch keine Stadt, die ihren Rat nicht besetzen konnte, weil sie nicht in der Lage sind, die Stimmen auszuzählen.
Und wenn es länger dauert, dauert es halt länger.
Genau.
Sonst noch irgendwas? Dieses Listenprinzip in dem Sinne stellt ja keiner in Frage. Das ist ja das Primat der Parteibildung.
Genau, das Listenprinzip besteht an der Stelle eben noch genauso. Der Wähler hat dann eben nur die Möglichkeit, in der Liste zu sagen, okay, nicht nur die Liste, sondern auch der Kandidat soll eben vorne stehen und das entsprechend mehr gewichtet werden.
Wenn man jetzt so im, vielleicht mal so ein bisschen von dieser Bundestagswahl in diesem speziellen Fallbundesrepublik Deutschland mal weggeht und einfach mal wahlen und sozusagen Wunsch, Massenwunscherfassung in irgendeiner Form als solches thematisieren. Jeder kennt das vielleicht, der in irgendeinem Verein ist. Da muss dann regelmäßig mal ein Vorstand gewählt werden. Und da mag es viele geben, die sich immer einig sind. Und das ist dann sowieso immer der gleiche Kegelslobkönig. Aber natürlich möchte man gerne ein System haben, wo eben der Wunsch des Einzelnen maximal Ausdruck verliehen wird. Häufig habe ich das erlebt. Es wird jetzt ein Vorstand gewählt. Man hat da irgendwie fünf, sechs Leute, die bestimmt werden sollen. Wie geht man dann am besten vor? Also was gibt es denn da so für Methoden? Weil das Problem ist ja dann zum Beispiel angenommen, man stimmt jetzt, sagen wir mal die Frage, stimmt man für jeden Einzelnen ab, der da drin ist? Stimmt man für alle gemeinsam ab? Wenn man für alle gemeinsam abstimmt, was heißt das? Habe ich jetzt eine Stimme? Ich wähle jetzt nur eine einzige Person, die mir am liebsten ist. Aber mir sind auch noch andere lieb, die muss ich dann aber weglassen, weil ich ja nur eine Stimme habe. Oder habe ich dann irgendwie fünf Stimmen, die ich dann gleichmäßig verteile? Und was bedeutet das dann in der Summe? Also was für Systeme kennst du und siehst du da noch, die da vielleicht diesen Gerechtigkeitsanspruch vor sich her tragen?
Ja gut, da gibt es natürlich eine ganze Menge Systeme, die da ihre verschiedenen Vor- und Nachteile haben. Ich meine, das Einfachste hatten wir ja schon mit der relativen Mehrheitswahl. Jeder hat eine Stimme für einen Kandidaten. Und wer meisten Stimmen hat, der ist es.
Aber da hat man ja meistens das Problem, wenn dann die anderen, ok, also angenommen der, den ich jetzt am liebsten hätte, der kriegt jetzt nicht genug. Dadurch ist dann aber gleichzeitig ein zweiter gewählt worden, den ich auf gar keinen Fall haben möchte. Also ich kann sozusagen nicht sagen, wen ich anstatt dessen lieber hätte, wenn der es dann nicht wird.
Das Verfahren wird natürlich an der Stelle schwierig, wo man halt eben nicht zwei Kandidaten hat, sondern drei.
Oder mehr.
Oder mehr. Und man eben sozusagen gezwungen ist zu sagen, welche zwei sind denn jetzt irgendwie die, die da am Aussichtsreichen sind und wer von den beiden ist jetzt der Beste. So, und dann hat man natürlich schon irgendwo ein strategisches Wahlverhalten, was ja eigentlich gar nicht gewünscht ist. Man will ja am Anfang sozusagen, dass man den Besten hat, nicht der, der aus irgendeiner Strategie dann rauskommt. Da gibt es dann eine Verbesserung mit dieser absoluten Mehrheitswahl, wo man sagt, okay, macht man zuerst eine Wahl und wenn dann keiner mehr als die Hälfte der Stimmen hat, dann macht man noch eine Stichwahl.
Da muss man mindestens 50 Prozent der Stimmen bekommen.
Genau, da muss man mindestens 50 Prozent der Stimmen bekommen.
Die gegebenen gültigen Stimmen, muss man so sagen. Sonst ist man im Deadlock.
Wie man das immer machen will, man kann natürlich dann noch sagen, okay, das ist, bei drei Kandidaten funktioniert das vielleicht noch so ungefähr, aber das kann natürlich auch sein, dass dann irgendein Kandidat, den keiner ganz vorne stehen hat, dann sagt, eigentlich ist das der Kandidat, den dann jeder alternativ wählen würde. So, und dann gibt es da dieses Condorcet-Verfahren, oder besser gesagt Prinzip, weil es als Verfahren noch nicht ganz eindeutig ist. Da wählt man also sozusagen nicht einen Kandidaten, sondern man gibt so eine Präferenzliste ab und sagt, okay, der erste Präferenz an den, den ich dafür als als bestes geeignet finde, und dann den zweiten und dritten und bis zum letzten, oder bis man sagt, die sind alle gleich schlecht. So und dann kann man halt gucken, gibt es da irgendeinen Kandidaten, der sozusagen in einer Stichwahl gegen jeden anderen gewinnt?
Ja.
So und wenn es den gibt, dann hat der halt nach diesem Condorcet-Verfahren und Condorcet-Prinzip gewonnen.
Also wie läuft das? Wenn ich jetzt, was weiß ich, wir haben jetzt irgendwie zehn Bewerber für fünf Posten, oder geht es jetzt nur um einen Posten?
Es geht jetzt erstmal um einen Posten, wo man mehrere Kandidaten hat. Und wenn es jetzt einen Kandidaten gibt, der gegen jeden anderen in der Stichwahl gewinnen würde.
Also was gebe ich denn als Stimme dann ab? Eine Liste von Leuten oder eine Rangfolge?
Ja, du gibst eine Rangfolge. Du gibst also zu...
Das heißt, am liebsten wäre mir der. Und wenn es der nicht werden sollte, würde dann der. Und wenn nicht, ist dann der. Okay, und dann?
Und dann kann man aus dieser Liste eine Stichwahl simulieren, weil ja jede Stimme einen Kandidaten vor dem anderen setzt. Das heißt, bei einer Stichwahl kann man immer sagen, der würde bei zwei Kandidaten für den stimmen. Und wenn es dann einen Kandidaten gibt, der jede Stichwahl gewinnen würde, dann ist das der Condorcet-Sieger.
Aber das ist nicht extrem knifflig auszuzählen. Da muss man ja im Prinzip auf alle Stimmzettel gleichzeitig schauen. Man vergleicht dann erst immer nur den ersten Platz? Oder wie läuft das?
Wie man das konkret macht, da gibt es dann verschiedene Varianten. Es kann durchaus passieren, dass es keinen solchen Sieger gibt, der wirklich gegen jeden in einer Stichwahl gewinnt. Sondern es kann sein, A gewinnt in einer Stichwahl gegen B, B gewinnt in einer Stichwahl gegen C, aber C wird dann in einer Stichwahl gegen A gewinnen. Und das ist dann sozusagen dieses Eroche-Unmöglichkeitstheorem, das sagt, dass so richtig jede Bedingung kann man also an der Stelle nicht lösen. Und an der Stelle muss man dann halt eben ein Verfahren finden und sagen, okay, hier diesen Kreis, den Schlangen, jetzt irgendwie durch und wir müssen die Entscheidung irgendwie anders fällen. Aber es gibt eben ziemlich viele Verfahren, die eben den Condorcetsieger bestimmen. Und wenn es den nicht gibt, dann irgendeinen, der dann doch relativ gut ist. So unterscheiden sich die Verfahren.
Ist das jetzt nur so eine Theorie oder wird das auch benutzt?
Ich glaube, da gibt es Vereinswahlen, wo das implementiert ist, dass eben der Condorcetsieger dann eben der Gewählte ist. Oder eben, falls es so einen Kreis gibt, dann eben irgendeinen, nach einer anderen Entscheidung. Aber es gibt auch andere Verfahren, die dann...
Ich glaube, die Methode wird auch zum Beispiel in der Open-Source-Welt bei Debian und so weiter zum Einsatz gesetzt.
Das kann sein. Wo das konkret ist, weiß ich nicht.
Das ist also wirklich ein Kandidat für eine automatisierte, computergestützte Auszählungsmethode.
Das ist eine sehr komplexe Stimme ab. Das ist dann schon einfacher, wenn man das automatisiert.
Das heißt, das kann man eigentlich auch nur mit Systemen machen, wo man wirklich einen hohen Vertrauensgrad hat oder wo sozusagen die Auszählung als solche sehr öffentlich ist?
Ja, das wird natürlich bei mehr Stimmen dann eben entsprechend schwierig. Eine andere Möglichkeit ist dieses Border-Verfahren, wo man Punkte verteilt.
Border?
Border, B-O-R-D-A. Wenn man jetzt fünf Kandidaten hat, dann kriegt der erste Kandidat fünf Punkte und der zweitbeste vier und der dritte drei, der nächste zwei und der letzte einen. Das sind dann sozusagen die Border-Punkte, die man verteilt. Da kann man natürlich am Schluss die Punkte zusammenzählen, die jeder Kandidat bekommen hat und der am meisten Punkte hat, der ist dann gewählt. Das ist ein Verfahren, wobei man hier manchmal auch kritisiert, dass dieser Konter-Aussettsieger, soweit es einen gibt, der sozusagen jeden schlagen würde, bei dem Verfahren vielleicht nicht unbedingt gewinnt.
Das kann man ja direkt vergleichen, weil man ja im Prinzip dasselbe Wahlprinzip hat.
Ja, ja, genau. Beziehungsweise das führt dann vielleicht auch zu irgendeinem strategischen Wählen, dass man sagt, ok, Kandidat A ist der Beste, der kriegt jetzt mal eine 5 Punkte. Klar, aber Kandidat B, das ist wohl der Zweitbeste, aber der kriegt jetzt nicht 4 Punkte, weil ich will ja Kandidat A haben, also kriegt er jetzt erstmal irgendwie nur einen. Das ist natürlich eine Strategie, die man da dann reinsetzen kann, die man bei dem Condoset-Prinzip dann eben nicht mehr hat.
Also im Prinzip so ähnlich wie auch hier bei dieser Eurovision-Wahl, wo dann irgendwie da diese Lieder...
Ja genau, das ist ja auch so was, dass man eben dann erstmal der Erste kriegt viele Punkte, der Nächste kriegt ein paar Punkte weniger und der Dritte kriegt noch ein paar Punkte weniger.
Wobei es halt nicht mehr den Linear gestaffelt ist, sondern man hat sozusagen auch noch so eine Gewichtung.
Genau, man kann das irgendwie anders, kann man das immer noch gewichten. So und dann gibt es sowas wie eine übertragbare Stimme, wo man sozusagen die Kandidaten nacheinander streicht, bis einer 50 Prozent der Stimmen hat.
Das ist jetzt noch ein anderes Wahlprinzip.
Ja, genau, frag mich jetzt nicht, wie das heißt. Das könnte jetzt Krupps-Verfahren sein. Ich bin mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher, wie das heißt. Wo man dann sagen kann, okay, man gibt auch wieder die Reihenfolge ab. Man muss aber nicht mehr alle Stimmen erfassen, sondern man guckt einfach nur aus, wer ganz oben drauf steht und der, der am wenigsten Stimmen hat, fliegt jetzt schon mal raus. Von dem, der jetzt rausgeflogen ist, gucken wir, was hat denn jetzt als 2. und 3. Präferenz. Also erstmal die 2., die nächste Präferenz. Verteilt die Stimme dann sozusagen wieder um und guckt dann, hat jetzt jemand mehr als 50 Prozent und wenn das nicht der Fall ist, guckt man eben weiter.
Kumswahl heißt das?
Nee, ich glaube, das heißt IRV, Instant Runoff.
Ah, Instant Runoff Voting.
Genau, das heißt also da fliegt dann immer der letzte Kandidat oder der nach diesem Prinzip Unbeliebteste fliegt dann raus und die Präferenzen, die die ER hatte, die werden dann als Stimmen auf andere Kandidaten verteilt. Und das eben so lange, bis dann einer mehr als 50 Prozent der Stimmen hat. Was eben spätestens dann erreicht ist, wenn...
Also auch hier wieder ein relativ komplexes Auswertungsverfahren, wo man dann nachrechnen muss und auch jede Stimme mehrmals quasi wieder in den Pult.
Ja, je nachdem, wie die Stimmen dann verteilt sind. Wenn man eine klare Mehrheit hat, dann braucht man das nicht. Aber wenn das dann irgendwie unklar ist, und man dann vielleicht irgendwie Blöcke hat und Kandidaten, mehrere Kandidaten in einem Block, dann kann das natürlich durchaus passieren. Dann gibt es noch ein Verfahren, Approval Voting, die Wahl per Zustimmung. Da kann man dann nur noch Ja oder Nein wählen. Oder Eins oder Nichts. Man kann also jedem Kandidaten, dem man das Amt zutraut, eine Stimme geben. Den anderen gibt man keine. Dann ist gewählt, wer auch die meisten Stimmen hat.
Das heißt, man kann mehrere Kreuze verteilen. Also alle, die für mich in Frage kommen würden, kreuzt sich an.
Das ist auch ein Verfahren.
Man kann also auch alle wählen oder keinen.
Genau, man kann alle wählen oder keinen.
Das ist ein Teil der ungültigen Stimmen, relativ niedrig.
Wobei man dann wenigstens einen ankreuzen sollte und auch einen freilassen sollte. Sonst hat die eigene Stimme überhaupt keine Aussage.
Es erhöht die Wahlbeteiligung.
Genau. Da gibt man also wenigstens dem, wo man sagt, das ist der Beste, selbst wenn er keine Chance hat, der kriegt auf jeden Fall die Stimme. Und den, den man als Schlechtesten hält, der kriegt auf jeden Fall keine Stimme. Dazwischen hofft man, dass sich dann irgendwo das mit der Taktik dann auch zurückhält. Gibt es an der Stelle natürlich auch, dass es dann sozusagen die Interpretation, dass man eben sagt, dass der, der gewählt wird, kriegt dann eben auch eine deutliche Mehrheit. Und das heißt, relativ viele stehen dahinter und sagen, der ist dafür geeignet. Auch wenn da noch drei andere sind, die sind genauso gut dafür geeignet. Aber der, der jetzt gewählt ist, ist auf jeden Fall dafür geeignet. Das ist das, was man dadurch dann sozusagen aneinander ausdrücken will. Das ist dann also die Zustimmungswahl. Ja, ich glaube, jetzt war ich an der Stelle so durch.
Was ist denn da jetzt persönlich am praktischsten? Ich meine, das ist ja so ein bisschen so eine Abwägung, von leicht zu verstehen beim Wählen, zu leicht auszuzählen.
Beim Wählen sind eigentlich alle einfach, weil jeder weiß ja, wer der Beste ist und wer der Zweitbeste ist und wer völlig ungeeignet ist und kann da ja so eine Reihenfolge reinbringen. Auszählen kann natürlich schwierig werden. Da sind eben manche dabei, wo man dann sozusagen iterativ auszählen muss, was sich aber auch immer nur auf einen Bruchteil der Stimmen bezieht. Bis dann alle verteilt sind, dauert dann natürlich länger, während andere dann, wie im Zweifelsfall die einfache Mehrheitswahl, dann doch ziemlich viel von der Meinung, die dann bei den Wählern existiert, wegwirft und nicht beachtet. Das ist immer eine Abwägungsfrage, wo man eigentlich immer gucken muss, für welchen Zweck, woran liegt es überhaupt, was will man da überhaupt machen.
Würdest du meinen, dass jetzt diese Wahlsysteme, die explizit eine Rangfolge in der Stimme drin haben, den anderen in irgendeiner Form dann noch voraus sind, was die Gewichtung der Stimme als solcher betrifft?
Für die Gewichtung der Stimme sind sie natürlich besser.
Also sind die dann auch gerechter? Kann man das so bewerten, oder ist das schwierig?
Ja gut, wird natürlich dann mehr von der Stimme, von dem, was die Wähler wollen, dann auch ins Ergebnis kommen. Man will ja vermeiden, dass das Wahlergebnis, was am Schluss rauskommt, dem widerspricht, was die Wähler eigentlich wollen. So, und wenn man jetzt, am Beispiel der der relativen Mehrheitswahl, drei Kandidaten hat, wo man sagt, okay, zwei, die sind irgendwie gelb und einer ist irgendwie lila und der lila Kandidat, der kriegt jetzt irgendwie 40 Prozent und die anderen beiden 30 Prozent. So, dann ist der lila Kandidat gewählt und die gelben mit 60 Prozent sind außen vor. Das ist ja irgendwo nicht das, was man haben will.
Das erzeugt auch echt eine Menge Streit, habe ich mal gemerkt.
Genau, und das führt eigentlich auch dazu, dass die Kandidaturen irgendwo dann auch abgesprochen werden müssen. Also man muss sich sozusagen schon vorher im Klaren sein, dass eigentlich von den Gelben nur einer antreten darf, damit die Wähler wissen, was sie machen sollen. Oder man muss den Gelben Wählern vorher genau sagen, der wird jetzt gewählt, aber das wird sozusagen aus der Hand der Wähler genommen. Das sollen ja die Wähler entscheiden und das soll nicht bei der Aufstellung der Kandidaten sozusagen entschieden werden. Deswegen ist sozusagen die relative Mehrheitswahl irgendwo kein besonders gutes Verfahren.
Bist du irgendwo in einem Verein Mitglied, wo gewählt wird?
Nicht? Doch, ich glaube immer irgendwelche Wahlen, aber da gibt es meistens Mehrheitswahlen. Aber jetzt fällt mir eigentlich nur hier die Idee.
Aber da ist noch kein neues Wahlverfahren vorgeschlagen?
Da habe ich noch keine Wahlverfahren vorgeschlagen.
Bist du mit der Bundestagswahl beschäftigt?
Ja, genau. Und bei Vereinswahlen ist das ja meistens auch so, dass man froh ist, dass es da überhaupt jemanden gibt, der sich für irgendwelche Sachen zur Verfügung stellt.
Ich habe auch schon so verschiedene Wahlen beigewohnt, wo dann auch wirklich, wie soll ich sagen, also genau dieses Problem, was du auch gerade beschrieben hast. Ein Kandidat findet eigentlich eine Mehrheit, aber nur, weil eigentlich alle anderen, die aber so in sich viel näher beieinander sind, da sich so recht keiner durchsetzen konnte. Und danach einfach bei allen, oder sagen wir mal bei einer Mehrheit, das Gefühl zurückblieb, dass das jetzt einfach mal überhaupt nicht das ausgedrückt hat, was man eigentlich wählen wollte. Was dann natürlich auch ein Problem für den Gewählten ist, weil er sich dann sozusagen vom Staat weg einer Fundamentalopposition in der Basis gegenüber sieht und eigentlich auch nicht arbeiten kann.
Ja, ich glaube im Verein ist das wahrscheinlich sogar noch schwieriger als in einer großen Institution, wo man dann sagen kann, ok, ich bin jetzt hier irgendwie ins Parlament gewählt und kann meine Arbeit machen. Und wie man dann gewählt worden ist, da guckt man dann eben nicht mehr so genau hin.
Jetzt gibt es ja auch Vertreter, die sagen, dieses ganze Delegieren ist ein Problem an sich. Weil was man ja eigentlich versucht mit so einer Wahl ist ja zu sagen, ok, alles klar, jetzt ist Wahltag, jetzt nehme ich mich aller Themen an. Im Falle der Bundestagswahl sagt man ok, für die nächsten vier Jahre. Ich betrachte jetzt mal die ganze Themenkomplexität, die so dahin liegt, was natürlich in dem Sinne gar keiner macht. Weil erst mal hat man sowieso einen Tunnelblick, manche interessiert das gar nicht, bzw. selbst wenn es einen interessiert, wie soll man bitte all diese ganzen Themen in den Kopf kriegen und dann auch noch bewerten. Also ist da eine ganze Menge Bauchgefühl mit dabei und sagt ok, alles klar. Ich delegiere die Macht, um all diese Fragen zu entscheiden, dahin. Und dann ist die Wahl vorbei und am nächsten Tag geht schon wieder alles anders. Das ist ja unser akzeptiertes System. Das könnte man auch sagen, das geht ja auch nicht anders.
Natürlich geht es anders. Man kann natürlich auch sagen, die Leute sollen halt über die Einzelfragen alle selbst abstimmen oder über die relevanten Einzelthemen. Dann ist man in der Schweiz. Das Problem ist auch oder es gibt sozusagen auch ein Paradox mit dieser Parteienwahl, dass so eine Partei immer nur für jeden Wähler auch nur ein Kompromiss ist. Die Partei ist ja nicht unbedingt mit den Themen so vertreten, wie ich das will, sondern nur im Zweifel am besten. Die ist halt am besten, die trifft von den und den Punkten, die ich gerne vertreten sehen möchte, vertreten die Partei halt am meisten. Das kann natürlich am Ende dann trotzdem rauskommen, dass die Parteien, die am Schluss gewählt sind, Punkte vertreten, die gegen die Punkte, die die Mehrheit vertritt, gerichtet sind. Das kann es letztlich durch so ein Prinzip eben nicht vermeiden. Das ist eben der Kompromiss, den man macht. Und wenn man Pech hat, dann ist das halt so schlecht geregelt, dass sozusagen gegen die Volksmehrheit dann irgendwo regiert werden muss oder reagiert wird.
Jetzt gibt es ja auch so Proponenten. Ich glaube, das Ganze wird im Wesentlichen unter dem Begriff Liquid Democracy geführt, damit irgendwie vertraut, dass man halt quasi so eine permanente Delegation von Macht hat. Dass man einfach sagt, okay, ich habe jetzt hier permanent eine Stimme, die aber sozusagen permanent neu delegiert werden kann. Und je nachdem, wem ich sozusagen am meisten vertraue, wechsle ich sozusagen diese Delegation permanent.
Du ziehst sozusagen, machst jeden Tag deine Bundestagswahl bzw. wenn du deine Wahlentscheidung änderst, änderst du die tägliche.
Genau, man würde ja sagen, man kumuliert sozusagen, man wählt erst mal diese Delegierten, aber danach verleiht man diesen Delegierten nachträglich unterschiedliches Stimmgewicht innerhalb des Systems, innerhalb dieses Wahlzirkus sozusagen, in dem dann über die konkreten Sachfragen entschieden wird, um das noch weiter zu beeinflussen.
Ach so, du machst sozusagen für jedes Thema eine eigene Wahl an deinen Delegierten oder sagst...
Entweder nicht für jedes Thema, sondern eben auch sozusagen für diesen gesamten Themenkomplex, dass man eben sozusagen beobachtet, wie sich es verläuft und wenn die Sache halt aus dem Ruder läuft, dass man sagt, ok, ich...
Also sozusagen so eine Art kontinuierliche Wahl, es gibt eigentlich gar nicht mehr diesen Einwahltermin, sondern man kann jederzeit sagen, ok, jetzt gehe ich hier von A nach B.
Man stärkt einzelne Abgeordnete.
Ja, ist wahrscheinlich irgendwo schwierig zu implementieren. Weil man dann sozusagen dann irgendwo seine Stimme haben muss, die man dann umdrehen kann, was dann mit der geheimen Wahl nicht so ganz zusammenhängt. Und ich sag mal, wahrscheinlich erst mal auf der großen Ebene eher mehr so ein Gedankenexperiment. Ich glaub, man will es eigentlich auch gar nicht. Man könnte sich ja vorstellen, dass die Leute sozusagen kontinuierlich wählen, also jeder zu einem anderen Termin. Dadurch dann Kontinuierlichkeit da reinbringt. Aber man will ja auch nicht die ganze Zeit Wahlkampf haben. Also ich glaube, die Politiker haben sich da irgendwie so drauf eingestellt, dass irgendwann Wahl ist. Und dann erzählt man den Leuten, was man machen will und wird dann für sein Programm gewählt oder auch nicht. Und dann versucht man das in der Zeit, die man da hat, durchzusetzen, ohne dass man plötzlich befürchten muss, dass ein Jahr später plötzlich alles wieder ganz anders aussieht. Also ich weiß nicht, vielleicht für dieses Liquid-Modell gibt es vielleicht Punktpunkte, die dafür sprechen. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass das kommen wird. Schon allein, weil die Gewählten das nicht wollen.
Also es gibt wohl einige Parteien, die das intern sozusagen damit experimentieren. Und ich glaube, auch in Neuseeland gibt es eine Rechtslage, die das zumindest in Teilen erlaubt. Aber da bekomme ich jetzt selber einen Schwimm, das weiß ich nicht.
Also in Neuseeland haben die halt für das nationale Parlament so ein ähnliches System, wie das bei uns ist.
Naja, vielleicht ist dafür auch nochmal Raum, in einem eigenen Chaosradio Express, um solche neuartigen Wahlsysteme zu besprechen. So, wie weit sind wir denn jetzt hier eigentlich gekommen? Also vielleicht fassen wir nochmal so zusammen. Innerhalb des Wahlsystems Bundesrepublik Deutschland, was wir haben, gibt es halt das konkrete Problem der Überhangmandate. Das ist sozusagen der offensichtliche Bug. Der ist jetzt eigentlich beschlossen, dass er mal geändert werden sollte.
Genau, der ist jetzt für die nächste Bundestagswahl nochmal bestätigt worden. Das heißt, darf jetzt noch einmal mit Fehler gewählt worden. Der Korrekturversuch wurde jetzt halt nochmal abgeblockt. Aber bei der danach folgenden Bundestagswahl muss man eben verfassungsgemäßes Wahlrecht gefunden haben.
Ja, haben wir noch irgendwas wichtiges vergessen?
Ganz wichtig ist die Landtagswahlsysteme. Da tritt der Fehler so nicht auf. Das sind meistens ähnliche Systeme wie bei der Bundestagswahl, wo man halt eine oder meistens zwei Stimmen hat, wo dann allerdings diese Verrechnung in die kleinere Einheit nicht stattfindet. Beziehungsweise wenn sie stattfindet, gibt es Ausgleichsmandate. Das heißt, Überhangmandate sind auf Landesebene nicht das System. Und auf Kommunal-Ebene sieht es noch ein bisschen bunter aus, kumulieren, panaschieren hatten wir ja.
Gibt es denn überhaupt Gemeinden, die auch so mit neuen Wahlsystemen rum experimentieren?
Die Gemeinden haben da an der Stelle ja nichts zu sagen. Das ist ja dann eine Landesgeschichte. Also wie in den einzelnen Städten gewählt wird und Gemeinden, das entscheidet dann immer der Landtag. Da hat dann höchstens eine Gemeinde das Recht zu sagen, so wollen wir das aber nicht. Liebes Parlament, vielleicht könnt ihr das ein bisschen anders machen, aber das ist eben nicht das, was eine Gemeinde entscheiden darf.
Ja, Martin, würde ich sagen, haben wir uns jetzt zusammengepackt, hier das Paket. Vielen Dank für die Ausführung. Zu der Ist-Situation Wahlrecht und Wahlsysteme, zumindest mit Schwerpunkt Bundesrepublik Deutschland. Und ja, damit beenden wir hier den kleinen Podcast. Zwei Stunden haben wir wieder vollbekommen. Das dachte ich mir auch schon vorher, dass das mal wieder recht umfangreich wird, das Thema.
Da können wir eine Stunde dranhängen.
Ja, da gibt es bestimmt auch noch eine ganze Menge Aspekte, die man sonst noch beleuchten kann, was euch gefällt hat und welche Themen in Richtung Wahlrecht, Demokratie, Systeme und so weiter, man hier sonst noch mal beleuchten sollte. Da freue ich mich schon auf eure Kommentare im Blog, auf blog.chaosradio.ccc.de, wie gehabt. Ja, dann noch mal danke, Martin.
Ja, und im Internet bei wahlrecht.de.
Genau, bei wahlrecht.de alles nachzuschlagen. Ich denke, da werdet ihr auch jetzt die weiteren Fortgänge dort nachschlagen. Habt ihr da noch irgendwelche Ressourcen, auf die du vielleicht noch mal hinweisen möchtest, die jetzt für Hörer auch interessant sein könnten? Also was ihr sozusagen auf dieser Webseite alles so habt?
Ja gut, die relevanten Urteile stehen da drin, so eine Dokumentation der Wahlprüfungen. Also unsere Wahlprüfung, auch der von Ulrich mit den Wahlcomputern. Und wir wollen jetzt natürlich auch dokumentieren, was jetzt an Unfug letzte Woche erzählt worden ist zu der Wahlreform. Warum das denn besser ist, dass man am besten nichts tut und sich erst mal hinsetzt und abwartet.
Und ihr habt auch eine ganze Menge Wahlergebnisse, Termine?
Ja, wir haben die Termine, die umgegangen sind.
Da gab es auch noch eine Diskussion um die Fraktionsstärke durch den Austritt von...
Ja, genau, das ist so ein Randthema gewesen. Durch die Überhangmandate gab es ein Urteil 1998, dass, wenn in einem Bundesland, wo Überhangmandate aufgetreten sind, einer der direkt gewählten Kandidaten aus dem Bundestag ausscheidet. Also entweder weil er stirbt oder keine Lust mehr hat oder irgendwie ein anderes Angebot annimmt. Dann war es bis dahin so, dass ein Abgeordneter von der Liste nachgerückt ist. Und da gab es dann wirklich einen Einspruch gegen so ein Nachrücken, wo der Beschwerdeführer Recht bekommen hat, wo dann gesagt wurde, ist nicht mehr. Und in so einem Fall würde dann sozusagen das Mandat dann ersatzlos verschwinden. So und das passiert halt eben, wenn ein Abgeordneter stirbt oder irgendwie was anderes macht. Und jetzt in diesem Fall ist es so, dass ein Abgeordneter der CDU aus Sachsen, wo im Bundestag, wo Übermandate angetreten sind, ins Europäische Parlament gewählt worden ist. Und es gibt jetzt so eine Ausschließungsklausel. Also ein Abgeordneter aus dem Europäischen Parlament, der darf nicht im Bundestag sitzen. So und der hat dann gesagt, okay, jetzt die letzte Sitzung habe ich mitgemacht. Und ich weiß nicht, irgendwie diese Woche muss er sich, glaube ich, entscheiden, ob er jetzt ins Europäische Parlament geht. Wir da wohl machen. So und nach der Hochrechnung wäre dann die Union, die verliert dann halt diesen einen Sitz, genauso stark wie die SPD. Aber jetzt, wo die SPD dann vor zwei Wochen dann eben auch um einen einen Sitz geschrumpft ist, dass sie dann die Piratenpartei verloren hat, also der Abgeordnete Taus, der ja aus der Fraktion ausgetreten ist, hat sich das jetzt auch wieder relativiert und die CDU wird dann immer noch einen Sitz mehr haben als die.
Hätte das dann irgendwelche Auswirkungen gehabt überhaupt?
Die Auswirkungen, also eine Auswirkung wäre, dass man sagen kann, okay, wir können jetzt mal die ganzen Ausschüsse, die jetzt wahrscheinlich eh nicht mehr tagen werden, nochmal neu berechnen und irgendeinen Ausschuss gibt es dann, glaube ich, wo die SPD dann verlangen könnte, dass man den letzten Sitz bei los entscheidet. Aber sonst gibt es keine konkreten Auswirkungen. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass jetzt der Kanzler neu gewählt werden muss oder sonst irgendwas. Das ist also keine Mehrheit, die irgendwo relevant ist.
Gut, also wenn ihr euch darüber informieren wollt, ob irgendeine Meldung bezüglich Wahlrecht, Wahlsystem, Abgeordnetenverteilung oder Fraktionsstärke eine Relevanz hat, dann findet ihr sicherlich eine Antwort auf wahlrecht.de. So, jetzt machen wir aber kein neues Kapitel auf, sondern ich sage jetzt einfach mal Tschüss und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und bis bald bei Chaosradio Express.
Auf Wiedersehen!